[Music]
homie look what I become
okay so guys it feels like it was uh a
month ago or two months ago but actually
the last time we did a pbd podcast home
team was July 25th which is more than
three weeks ago okay so I almost we
don't even know each other what's your
name great to meet you yeah Patrick
great to meet you pleasure Mr Ellsworth
what's your name
hey pbd podcast folks out there it's
great to spend some time with you guys
great to be back we got a lot happened
uh uh a khabib uh Nora Muhammad
interview I did uh Habib UFC which will
be uh released I think tomorrow I saw
the premiere the what do you call it the
intro today I asked him a question I
think this clip two clips that I asked
him about Habib I think those two are
going to be intense one of them when I
asked them I said Habib in the U.S we
have about 100 plus genders how many
genders you have in Russia it's a very
interesting answer he gives it's
Technical and then the other one I asked
him about uh he loves Michael Jordan and
when you much less dance
in the documentary Michael when his
father dies he steps away from the game
but he comes back to win three more I
said when you watch that documentary and
you got emotional did it inspire you
want to come back and win one more for
your dad you have to wait for that one
it's going to come out here soon got a
good time Vegas was great we had a lot
of stuff going on I had great meetings
in Vegas with a bunch of different
people but we got to get into some
stories because of a lot has happened
the last few weeks one
Snow White is pissing a lot of people
off saying she doesn't want a she's not
going to have a love story with another
man because she wants to be a leader and
she was crying yesterday because we were
hurting her feelings after she said some
stuff he's a stop the stalker so Rachel
you're 22 years old you should be able
to take it no one asked you to go into
Hollywood no one asked you to call out
people who have for decades loved the
brand of Disney until recently so yes
you are going to get called out by them
and today we're going to talk about the
Michael burry okay from the movie Big
Short makes a 1.6 billion dollar bet
against the stock market the last time
he did that everybody called him
absolutely crazy until he was right and
they made a movie about him so we don't
know if they're gonna make another movie
about him right now or he's going to be
wrong the CIA China says something about
the CIA I want to play this clip for you
guys here in a minute you got to see it
Target reports first quarterly sales
drops in six years the first sales up in
six years after pride month disaster
uh there's a new movement going on uh
gang I don't know if you guys want to
subscribe to this movement it's called
the meet the stay at home dads they are
on the rise as four men drop out of work
and Skip College this is an inside his
story Tom's got some feedback on it Tom
on the pen uh ESPN deal with bar stool
Dave Portnoy who bought it back for a
buck we'll talk about that ESG SMP guess
what they're scaling back on debt
ratings and they're no longer saying we
are looking for your ESG score which
means we are making some progress folks
with all of you talking about it sharing
whatever content you see this is good
heart attacks at record level after
pandemic the telegraph this is deeply
concerning wait to see the numbers we
have to talk about what happened with
Trump the charges Georgia a lot of
people are concerned some are not the
camp is getting more fired up about
wanting him to get into office so he can
get back to what these guys are doing
with the doj weaponizing it against them
again we'll talk about that today uh
Ronda centers may have gotten his
biggest endorsement ever done don't say
who it is we're comment on the one the
biggest this is possibly the biggest
endorsement when when this person
endorses you you know you're doing
something and and wait to see who it is
we have to talk about the genocide
that's going on in our our media with uh
nagorno with what Azerbaijan is doing
devastating stories that I'm hearing
from there uh former Biden uh uh Senator
told him he'd kicked the [__] out of him
he said it to him when he touched his
wife he said this on a TMZ show I think
last week or a week and a half ago
um then we got a bunch of other stories
Americans credit card debt record
break-in I got two day two numbers I
want to show you about traditional TV
and streaming what's happening with it
the video of what happened in Topanga
Mall where we had our office right
across the street that's the shop that
was my number one mall to go shopping
crazy they stole three hundred thousand
dollars worth of stuff out of
Nordstrom's Wall Street Tom's got an
update for us with commercial real
estate and Anheuser-Busch we actually
had a chance to meet the CEO of
Anheuser-Busch last week with Dana White
at the UFC a super slap event that we
went to which was something else okay so
let's go into Michael Brewery Tom
Michael burry makes a 1.6 billion dollar
bet against the stock market uh which
has got a lot of people talking so
Michael Murray famed for predicting the
2008 financial crisis and The Big Short
has positioned bearish bets against the
U.S stock market he purchased put
options against 739 million dollars in
Invesco QQQ trusts ETF shares and 886
million in spdr SMP ETF shares signaling
a possible Market downturn Brewery bets
indicate a defense offensive stance as
put options increase in value with
declining stock prices while exact
amount risks aren't disclosed due to
filing limitations very previous high
profile predictions lend attention to
his Market actions despite a history of
accurate predictions such as shorting
tech stocks during the.com bubble some
bets like his short position on Tesla in
2020 have misfired burry's recent
options moves against the market could
be part of a broader strategy that isn't
fully evident from the filings Tom well
Michael burry interesting guy a lot of
credibility subject to The Big Short he
was in there
um
prominent figure and he's known as a
contrarian and a contrarian looks for
markets that are out of sequence or that
are overcooked and they play against him
just like you might call him a bear and
so he has a history of this looking for
overcooked things so it's not really a
headline that he's a contrarian and this
is a defensive move so he might have
three four five billion dollars of total
investment he's putting 1.6 against the
market and what's interesting just to
see he's pointing at the S P 500 and
there's a lot of people including me
that think that's a little overcooked
because 92 of those stocks are kind of
stuck but seven of them remember they
were calling the Magnificent Seven Tesla
Mark you're going up is it that the only
thing that's been in the S P 500 was the
Tesla bounce up it was number one
because it went from like 110 to 220
where it is now is 265 a week ago and
that Magnificent Seven carried it and so
he's saying I don't think the
Magnificent Seven can keep doing this
quite so long and so I'm gonna bet
against it so when he bets against it he
thinks it's going to air out but he's
had a history of defensive postures and
he's been right more than he's wrong
although he did trip on Tesla in 2020
but he didn't lose a huge ton but he had
to back out of that position so but when
Michael Brewery says hey I'm thinking it
might rain tomorrow it's never a bad
idea to buy an umbrella let's take a
look at what happened to SMP yesterday
that means this is a slight drop nothing
crazy Rob can you go to the the the
greedy in text that Adam always talks
about whatever that in there agreed
index
where would you think we are right now I
already know exactly it's greedy I think
with 60 70 it's actually neutral right
now okay there's dead even so if it's
neutral right now he's making a position
like this
um I don't know look this is not a 100
no one in the market is a hundred
percent free throw shooter
um no one is but this guy if he was a
free throw shooter Tom he's like a mark
price and some people don't know who
Mark Price is I'll give you more modern
day one he's like a Steve Nash Steve
Nash 92 topic he's up to exact numbers
but he when he's when he's calling shots
like this people listen go ahead Tom hey
uh Rob can you pop that back up real
quick pop it wrong so since the FED
added the other quarter point one month
ago extreme greened 80 one week ago 62.
now 51. so there is a sliding Market
sentiment coming out with a lot of
consumer stats we'll talk about housing
a few things later but Pat there's a lot
coming out with that interest rate raise
and you can see over the last month the
index has
definitely sliding back let me just add
to that so we've we've covered Michael
burry in The Big Short here uh multiple
times open invite to the podcast Michael
Berry yeah you're allowed to uh
reveal yourself
um you know I think he found it as a
company was called what Scion Capital it
became famous it was Christian Bale that
played him with a weird haircut in the
sandals and the eye so he's Christian
Bale also has an open invitation there
yeah there you go thank you uh great
plug right there yeah as much
credibility as he has you know he's not
Nostradamus he is more right than he's
wrong even more so what's more telling
is you know worry making his prediction
someone who has I believe has even more
credibility than Michael Murray is
Warren Buffett and Warren Buffett was
you know how much cash did he have on
reserves during covet like almost a
hundred billion dollars something insane
yeah he played it right I mean he's got
a track record Beyond anybody what was
interesting is that he uh Berkshire
Hathaway his company actually sold I
think eight billion dollars of assets
recently in the uh Q3 so in Q2 they were
acquiring assets and Buffett actually
was selling off so uh if you don't
believe necessarily Michael burry's
prediction uh if you want a little more
weight to your argument Warren Buffett
got some things to say about this uh
important note the s p is what up 17
this year I want to say that nasdaq's
close to 30 percent something ridiculous
um Berry
shorted the QQQ what is that that it's
sort of a NASDAQ ETF right so what goes
up must come down s p
um he shorted that as well the spider
the spider ETF so
um you know fed has been sort of pausing
their rates for now we'll see what they
do we'll see what Jerome Powell does
inflations somewhere in the three
percent neighborhood when it was eight
nine percent I don't know a year ago so
the economy inflation unemployment is I
don't know navigating their all-time
lows uh three and a half or sorry around
three percent what is it Tom 39 so
there's a lot of information to process
here so it's uh good stuff to take note
of as I think what it comes down so
that's Autumn the average Joe hears
something like this what do you what do
you tell the average Joe like that this
guy's betting against the market what
would some guy that wants to jump on
board with this thing like how what how
would you go about it well I think if we
could just learn lessons from the last
two major downturns in the market which
was 2007 2008 Boom by 2010 the market
roared back and we went on what a
10-year Bull Run until kovid and then
covid
um we lost what 40 percent and then six
months later we were at all-time highs
so ultimately if you play the long game
you're gonna be fine so but for older
people you know if you're if you're not
in cash or bonds if you're still stock
heavy or if you have like company stock
that you're all in on be very wary got
you so yeah if you're somebody that's
the average person don't get to too
crazy about it it's going to be fine let
me go to the next story Wall Street is
ready to scoop up commercial real estate
on the cheap uh Wall Street firms like
Conan steers Goldman Sachs eqtx Exeter
and BGR racing billions to buy
distressed commercial real estate
including Office Buildings and
apartments at a fraction of a preview
previous price to plummeting values
factors such as interest rate spikes had
led to a 10 to 15 percent drop in
commercial property values with
potential for further 20 to 25 percent
decline the stress property volume
surged by 8 billion in Q2 and biggest
quarterly increase since 2020 owners
like Clarion partners and are now
offering offloading properties in San
Francisco office towers that sold for 41
million dollars after being purchased
for 107 million dollars in 2014. eight
years later it sold for 66 million
dollars less smaller investors attracted
by non-traded reads 100 billion raise in
seven years are targeted but
institutional funds with 145 billion for
Investments post competition Tom well
you know what's really interesting about
this remember when everybody was saying
BlackRock is buying up neighborhoods
they're buying up small homes and
they're going to be your landlord for
rent remember that earlier this year
well guess what they've turned their
attention to what is being known as the
regional banking crisis an original
banking crisis is the people that own a
lot of the paper on these buildings in
Los Angeles are very significant
Regional banks that are in California
similar to San Francisco and so the big
guys the PE money and the big banks are
just saying I'm ready to raise my market
share and overall real estate and raise
the market share of my portfolio and I'm
just waiting for the small Banks to be
in trouble and I'm going to come and buy
that paper from them at pennies and I'm
going to own the commercial office space
and see if there's an increase in the
future but right now what we're seeing
is the commercial real estate is is
crashing we've been seeing it and now
the big banks are about to step in so
the underlying story pbd is the big
banks are about to get bigger and the
regional banks are going to get bailed
out by the big Banks because the
regional banks are holding the mortgages
in a lot of those buildings hey Pat I'm
going to pull a Vinnie right now and
just uh ask you so I understand this
information that Tom just broke down
eloquently what does this mean for the
little guy I'm not in commercial real
estate you know I'm not a big real
estate guy what does this mean to the
average investor or the average person
looking to nothing nothing for the
little guy this this means a lot to the
bigger guys uh our audience you know you
know when we do it a live podcast 85 of
our business owners when they come down
here so they're the these are are a lot
of big of our our audience there's those
that want to be the big guy one day
meaning they want to be Financial fear
they're very aspirational they want to
grow you know they're they're also
wanting to question but there's an
audience of ours that is running a
business they're successful they want to
talk about serious issues in life of
politics religion Finance money things
like that but they're sometimes quiet as
well because they don't want to risk
losing their business so to come and
listen to what we have to send and
they'll go and talk about amongst their
peers this affects those
who are wanting to buy a building right
now if you're thinking about buying a
building right now this is a decent time
to buy it and it may even get better in
the next couple months but I don't think
the opportunity is going to be around
for too long with commercial real estate
I think right now is a decent time to
buy commercial real estate you know the
people going back to the office it's
it's gradually becoming like listen guys
if we tried it didn't work get your butt
back to the office or else there's a
video circulating with Dave Portnoy goes
to his office I don't know if you saw
this clip or not he's walking around
after he picks it up and we'll talk
about that here in a minute he's walking
around the office where the hell is this
guy where's that guy it's 10 o'clock
where is everybody how come they're not
at the office how many articles did this
guy write are you kidding me the last
three weeks he's only written seven
articles what the hell has this company
been doing who's been running this place
it's an incredible scene of a Founder
who put his blood and tears into the
company realizing nobody is working
right everybody is getting back into
working out of offices realizing that's
not working you know where we're going
to be remote now having said that
some companies went so far out that
they're going to have a hard time
bringing their people they spalled into
back into like it's like a father that
spoiled his kids so much by giving them
everything now you want to tell them you
got to go work and make your money daddy
you screwed me up already bro the days
of fixing Hunter Brighton are behind you
you can't face it's done so that part is
game so I think commercial real estate
still got an opportunity
um you know like right now my God we're
talking yesterday to our commercial real
estate guys from from the guys that we
work with here players and they said
look this is a sublease is a wide open
leases are wide open offices are you
know open for the price tag that you
want we're looking at a bunch of
different places with here Pompano 10
mile radius of course mayor Suarez would
like us to move to Miami and bring
vitamin back to Miami but it is a good
opportunity for buyers Tom I see your
hand it is a good opportunity for buyers
and uh what do you call it for buyers
and those that want to lease but I don't
think this is going to last a long time
and by the way if you have a white color
business Midtown nice white collar
business and you're looking for office
space now I mean pbd you could
practically do a how-to on this because
we went through this when we got you to
do how to on that we could both do a
how-to on this that you could take
advantage of the opportunity right now
to lower your lease cost on your
business if I was looking for two three
thousand square feet right now that's
probably tough but I'm looking for five
thousand seven thousand ten thousand
square feet for a mid-size white collar
business there are deals to be had in
your city you're absolutely right and if
there's only two years left on your
lease yes call them on the phone and
says be in my office and return this
what is your lease but we're dropping
the price you know it's crazy when I
lost my lease you you when I lost my
lease years ago when the tenant comes in
from Sunshine Realty in Granada Hills
and she says you're parking 200 people
here I'm getting fee fines and tickets
from Neighbors we have to kick you out
this is a small space of 3660 square
feet you're evicted they kicked us out
of this office in Granada Hills I went
around knocking on two three four five
hundred office is to ask who's
subleasing until somebody gave me an
office lease and I was in that office
for three years it was one of the best
decisions we made went to 8550 Balboa
Boulevard in Northridge but today
sublease opportunities are everywhere
Pennies on a dollar and you can ask I
want it to be all in leave your
computers leave your desk leave your
conference room leave the projector
everything you did leave it in there for
me I'm gonna use it so we're going to
come back to this day Port no video here
in a minute uh uh matter of fact if you
just want to play it right now for if
since it's 30 seconds so the audience
can see it here's Port no coming back to
the office how how stupid is this
[__] company like I bought it I've
owned it back for
less than 24 hours hey what time is it
right now
9 45.
we've got a couple people over here two
people
these [__] don't show up I'm
only available
9 45. look at this this is
you're gonna be the dumbest
[__] in the world not to show
up here like I'll be there early today
out there but respect to him as a
Founder for doing that is he based in
New York is that where they're based out
of yeah okay yeah how is this still a
thing even in New York how is work from
home still a thing like the Biden
Administration basically said covet was
done what in may we all knew it was done
well before that how is this actually
still a thing and then he did a video he
did a follow video about where he just
has a camera set up and he's doing the
time of everybody coming in eight four I
love it nine o'clock 10 30. I freaking
love good you know you know what idea I
would well anyways so you know how
there's this thing called Glassdoor okay
what's Glassdoor for people to go out
and write about you the company okay or
Yelp is you the business where is there
a glass store for employees right where
is there a glass store for employees if
you're listening to this if I had less
businesses we were running we would
develop that software and technology so
everybody is being knocked them out but
there's many employees that are
absolutely terrible employees that
should get their glass door ratings to
be out there where people realize if I'm
hiring this guy this guy doesn't come to
the office on time doesn't do this
doesn't do that there needs to be a
rating on them so this is a great
example of a Founder that's sitting
there saying what the hell are you guys
doing at 9 35 not coming to the office I
respect what he's doing and um I would I
would assume for a guy like that either
the guy's gonna show up
some of them are going to say screw you
and go talk [__] about him but a guy
like Dave portno he ain't going away
anytime soon he's going to be around for
a long time to come by the way very
happy he's back to run Barstool because
to me Barstool doesn't make sense
without Dave portno it's a brand that's
very much together it's great to see him
being back uh before we go into the
Barstool story and the biggest
endorsement around the Santa's guide I'm
going to give a quick shout out to our
sponsors your Masterworks gank at this
point of the game there's a couple
things I want you to be thinking about
uh I've I've done very form from uh for
myself on alternative assets I'm not
talking about real estate I'm not
talking about stock spawns mutual funds
crypto I've owned all of that stuff I've
owned gold I own precious metals all of
those things but when it comes down to
Alternative assets I'm at a Goldman
Sachs event and and our folks in uh what
do you call it Miami art basil the
entire conversation was about how many
of these people are investing into
expensive art you know five million
dollars 10 million dollars the other day
story about Jamie Diamond's art
collection Rob if you can pull this up
Jamie Diamond the CEO of JP Morgan you
know how big his art collection is he's
got a 900 million dollar art collection
Jamie Dam why does he have a 900 million
art collection now somebody may say I
don't have that kind of money I totally
get it I didn't start off with a lot of
money either what Masterworks allows you
to do is to buy shares in art like
Picasso Banksy you know whatever Warhol
that you may not be able to afford to
buy six hundred thousand dollars you can
buy 10 shares in it five shares in it I
love the work these guys are doing at
this point of the game I think they have
790 000 users with 800 million dollars
of assets under management if you want
to participate with these guys uh go to
masterworks.com forward slash uh uh is
it valuetainment wrap is it forward
slash value Tim and I think it's forward
slash pbd podcast okay got it so
masterworks.com forward slash pbd
podcast once again
masterworks.com forward slash Peabody
podcast and study what they're doing
everything is regulated like when I buy
baseball cards they're all graded these
are graded art so if anything happens
fraud Wise It's on them because you're
protected there so again go to
masterworks.com forward slash pbd
podcast we'll put the link below for you
as well having said that Tom
what's going on with uh uh Penn and and
the structure with what uh Dave Portnoy
did I'm gonna go to page five here read
this I'm gonna give it a hand it over to
you so again Dave Portnoy 10 ESPN deal
allows Barstool Sports founder Portnoy
to buy it back for ready one dollar to
buy back for a buck there porno quieted
back for dollars from Penn for a dollar
from Penn entertainment ESPN deal after
having initially sold it for 500 million
dollars the move was seen as a strategic
step to ensure the company's long-term
viability with portnoise anticipating
two or three more Decades of success pen
entertainment has previously acquired 30
to 36 percent
stake in Barstool Sports 463 million
dollars in 2020 and later completed the
acquisition by buying the remaining
shares for 388 million dollars a
subsequent 10-year two billion dollar
agreement with ESPN led to the remaining
renaming of Barstool Sports as ESPN bet
Port no acknowledge respect for the pen
team while highlighting the content
limitations posed by regulated
Industries Tom a buck 500 million
dollars two buck what happened here okay
let's dive in because the headline is
entrepreneur buys company back for one
dollar and everybody goes wow how did
that happen well it's not what it seems
so once upon a time pen entertainment as
you just said bought 36 then they bought
the rest so now they own 100 of Barstool
Sports
step one step two they said let's get
into OSB right which is online sports
betting DraftKings has about a 35 market
share FanDuel is about a 30 market share
MGM and Caesars each share about a 25
market share espns wanted to be there
because over the last five years what
have we seen the sports leagues have
warmed up remember when they thought the
DraftKings and um uh FanDuel were
radioactive we can't have betting logos
on the outside of of the Outfield walls
and in football stadiums remember they
were all nervous about this we can't
have gambling that close to it where
you're you're ordaining fantasy sports
we're making happy bets between guys now
you're just doing the full thing so the
leagues warm to this which meant that
OSB was growing like a freight train
last year it was 1.6 billion five years
ago it was barely 400 million so online
sports betting running what does that
have to do at bar stool
pen bot Barstool to create the Barstool
Sports Book which they successfully
created but when they went door-to-door
to Regulators in every state now Pat and
I know what this is about because in
insurance you have to go door to door in
every state for a thing called the DOI
Department of Insurance well there's
similar departments regulating gambling
in the states where it's legal where
it's not just legal at Indian casinos
it's legal throughout the state they
start going door to door and they're
like you have a compliance problem
what's a compliance problem these bar
stool guys have like nine podcasts they
talk about fantasy they talk about was
the game fixed was the ref High you
can't be saying that with your left hand
if you're running a sports book with
your right hand you follow so they kept
telling pen they got into
um I think it was Pennsylvania they got
into they kept tried to get into
Michigan Michigan gave them a hard time
so what Portnoy is saying content
limitations posed by regulated so Penn
is pulling its hair out because it can't
get into OSB and get the licenses in the
other state States so what does it do
it's looking for somebody that wants to
get into OSB maybe somebody who's
restructuring laying off Talent looking
for new Revenue ESPN and so they go to
ESPN and they said hey I got an idea
I give you a hundred million of this a
year and that was the 1.5 billion
dollars they did so for 10 years there's
a billion and at 500 million dollars in
warrants in other words to buy more so
I'll give you ESPN 1.5 billion we'll
rename this ESPN bet which you would
never have thought would have happened
though five years ago but now ESPN's and
OSB and the regulator said okay well
listen I'll look at your application if
you have a more controlled ESPN brand
but what are you doing about these bar
stool guys Penn said I'll be right back
they went to Dave portno I said Dave
buy your entire company back for a
dollar on all the corporate docks you
have 100 control and you have a and it's
all you we know not own we're not on the
board we're not there however I need you
to accept and sign this option agreement
that says if you ever sell the company
you'll give me 50 of the proceeds in
exchange you can't say anything about me
and there has to be a non-compete that
you'll never work with any other osbs
you understand but they can never do
gambling yeah so bar stool Sports can
talk fantasy all day long but they can't
disparage pen or ESPN and they have
things they need to do so if Portnoy
ever sells he gives them 50 of the money
but far as The Regulators are concerned
that one dollar decouples pen from
Barstool so they and new
BFF ESPN can go to all the Regulators
because they want a slice of it so did
Portnoy get control of his company and
the full board and everything back he
sure did but technically you and I both
know how Equity Works technically Penn
still is in for 50 and if he ever sells
they get 50 of the money but they
they don't let me get this out let me
get this straight so he can't do
anything with gambling moving forward no
he could talk fantasy sports but he
can't do OSB at all at all the bar stool
sports book that we've seen in casinos
goes away new yeah so can you Google
what percentage of the revenue was from
the bar stool OSB
what percentage of the revenue did
Barstow make from their OSB it was
relatively new and they were only a
limited number of states I don't have
the dollars let's see if Rob can find it
and Tom it's going to be called ESPN bet
now correct got you yep wow that's I
can't believe that they're gonna so
Portnoy does have full control full
creative control he's got the board he
can do whatever he wants he can't get
into OSB that's all it is and he said
I'm not worried about ever having to
give up half of the company I'm never
selling yeah yeah I mean go for it yeah
I just think
for a larger context I think the story
oh there you go so Barstool I'm sorry so
FanDuel accounts for 47 the national OSB
parent company flutter said Wednesday
with DraftKings and second amongst 35
Barstool Sports Book market shares
roughly five percent that time that five
percent is still a lot of money though
that's true for them that's five percent
that's gone no yeah Barstool loses that
that is now Penn and ESPN bet have five
percent of the market so it's so it's
almost like somebody buying our
insurance company and giving it back to
us and saying hey Pat I'm giving this
insurance company back to you but you
can never ever sell annuities again
never annuities is not yours that's the
one I don't care what you do with
security stocks Insurance you can't
touch annuities and I'm not on your
board but if you ever sell Pat this
coupon right here says you got to give
me half the money if you ever sell it I
got it okay that's how pens protecting
itself to get its money back someday but
Portnoy said I'm never going to sell
this they have a 50 million dollar
ebitda in a year you know he wants to
pay himself 20 million dollars pen can't
say nothing
nope if he monetizes it takes investors
or if he sells they get something so the
50 is only on sale it's not on ebitda
every year profits correct it's
monetization good for Dave so Dave's got
also yeah good so both parties win
that's right I actually think this is
good and they're hedging themselves
they're going after the bigger victory
for themselves they're betting on
someone that's going to make him more
money than Barstool okay so they're
bidding on a corporation instead of a
Founder this is when the founder Port
knows got to go proof to the market you
thought I was going to make money just
with your betting stuff watch what I do
here this is why I gotta you gotta love
capital and then it's gonna be a good
show next five ten years and by the way
if you're DraftKings or your FanDuel are
you sweating this morning because now
ESPN has been given a a green line 100
million dollars a year and a very
capable partner 10 to go after that
market I just love that it goes in the
office and now he's like everybody get
your ass to the office I'll just add
that I actually really appreciate the
trajectory of of Barstool so it was
founded in 2003 right everyone thinks
that hit the internet at in 2012 2013
Instagram founded in 2003 uh in a little
town in Massachusetts outside of Boston
uh Jewish kid Portnoy by the way really
yeah there you go you know those Jews in
that money oh
um so I think it's just really
impressive so 20 years later so what
what happened 2003 he starts this it's a
little newspaper they're talking fantasy
football they're interviewing gambling
it's just a little thing whatever Boom
the internet happens basically 2007 I
think they take it to AOL they're on the
internet boom 2012 2013 they're hitting
Instagram boom Saturdays are for the
boys everybody knows that Tom and they
just start blowing up and their content
is just Cutting Edge it's awesome it's
funny it's hilarious it's more than just
Sports it's pop culture hot chicks all
right all good and you know to see 20
years later where they're at is really
impressive and they're obviously making
a bet on him for another couple decades
so I think the to Circle back to this
you know how they say one bite everybody
knows the rules for sure one dollar Penn
gaming knows the rules now homie it's
also very interesting is there's an
evolution point there for Dave Portnoy I
thought was brilliant from about 2017
2021 they had their own channel channel
85 on Sirius and they were programming
it 24 7. so they had our programs
programs programs programs all kinds of
things and when that deal clunked in 21
that's where the rest of their podcast
came from they converted all of those
radio shows to podcasts so that's what
made Barstool Sports suddenly one of the
largest podcast Publishers and that's
where the pardon my take came and that
also is where they kind of hit some
bumps he found caller daddy right that's
their part that's right and he had and
like many media companies some of his
talent became free agents right um
caller Daddy became a free agent she
went somewhere else and uh also actually
there were two of them one of them
jumped off the show and then the other
one went by herself and then the other
one was um he was doing a live show at
the Super Bowl in 2017 and he had patent
McAfee simultaneously announced he was
retiring as a punter and starting the
Pat McAfee show and he was on Barstool
for two years and then he went off and
he just got I think it's 30 million
dollars a year from uh ESPN ESPN
sponsored by FanDuel yeah believe it or
not so Portnoy is it's a beautiful
Evolution if you only see the guy that's
raiding pizzas and being Rough Around
the Edges you know what that is a facade
and inside there there's a very very
shrewd guy and his CEO Erica nardini is
not to be trifled really impressive
people so let's let's go to this year
I'm going to transition into this which
is fantastic okay so Rob do me a favor
Rob can you pull up the chart of what's
streaming and cable did not this one the
other one that Brandon texted you what
streaming and cable did just last year
okay last year July of 2022 was a very
historic month here's why that was the
month where officially streaming Rob if
he can go back on the screen that was
the month where streaming passed up okay
no no you go back where you are you're
good I'm just saying put your mouse on
yeah right there that is the month where
streaming passed up cable
so if you look at cable it was going
down uh this is a two-year chart from 21
to 22. it went down it went down and
went down so boom it hits 34.4 percent
and streaming goes up to 34.8 now before
you go to the other one let's stay here
A year later to see where streaming goes
and where cable drops how big of a
difference would you think would happen
just one year if you go to the next
charge that the chart that the reports
just came out with is the following when
you go here you now see streaming went
to 38.7 so the lead they had was only
0.4 percent they go to 38.7 and cable
drops to 30 29.6 what's the difference
there roughly 9.1 the separation in one
year that means you're going from you
know first quarter to second quarter you
got a you know a touchdown lead all of a
sudden you got a 3-4 touchdown lead in
one quarter boom so this goes to 38.7 at
the top is what you YouTube Netflix Hulu
Prime Disney max 2B peacock Roku all
that stuff right cable getting crushed
however what is keeping cable what
happened no nothing yeah what what keeps
what's keeping Cable in business so
watch
Rob do me a favor uh before we go to
this I want you to think about this
three things we're talking to our guys
here yesterday uh shout out to uh
Brandon Kelly and Elon phenomenal
conversation we're having with these
guys
and here's what we saw the number one
thing that the three things that are
keeping Cable in business first thing is
all folks listening watching TV okay
they just want to go home and watch Fox
CNN MSNBC that's kind of how they get
their news no problem okay and there's a
timeline to that you know I'm 44 years
old I'm not living forever okay so old
folks are not going to be around forever
when they're watching what they're
watching number two is sports okay so
cable for the longest Sam has always had
Sports football soccer baseball you know
basketball we watch NBA on TNT right we
watch we consume Sports so what's
happening with sports lately sports
teams are now saying I'm gonna do it
myself and not only that streaming
companies are now offering money to who
Sports deals and saying hey bring NFL to
us we're Amazon bring this to us so
Cable's like wait a minute wait a minute
we thought our only competition was
DirecTV and now DirecTV is running out
of money but you guys can't pick this up
to streaming why would anybody want to
watch streaming and Tom who one day said
I said dude I gotta watch this game Tom
how am I going to be able to watch this
game and says Pat go on Hulu you can
watch the baseball game on a funnel so
what are you talking about I'm younger
than Tom but when it comes to technology
Tom's young gonna meet yeah so I'm like
Tom show me how to do this I go home I'm
like are you kidding me you mean to tell
me I can watch your game I say yeah Pat
just watch it here I remember this
conversation when I had because cable
went out in your neighborhood yeah
because cable went out of my
neighborhood oh yeah so I'm watching
this I'm like sick on your phone and
your iPad at HD but but this is the last
one let me tell you what the last one is
I want to ask this question you guys all
know the answer to this question except
for Rob all right we had dinner last
night and we had a good conversation
about this folks if you're watching this
what percentage of cable TV
do you think
their advertisement comes from Big
Pharma what percentage Rob I'm actually
curious enough for people to answer this
and you want Rob to know too don't look
it up I want you to guess what what do
you think the number is what percentage
of cable TV advertisement you think
comes from Big Pharma I'd like to see
what the chat has to say as well they
Googled it already they got the answers
you had to randomly guess what to say
above 60 so 60 to 70 go Google it now
and see what percentage of advertisement
money for cable comes from Big Pharma
wow and and wait till I drop this on you
on on what do you think is going to
happen here next if you can pull this up
uh uh what's the number
75 percent wrong oh my God 75 and this
is as of two months ago drug dealer May
11 2023 is the article 75 is coming from
drug companies Pharma so check this out
let me break you to the cable folks that
are giving all these big ass contracts
to people like ESPN and fox and CNN and
ABC and a lot of these guys to be honest
with you good for them for getting their
money but they're getting overpaid
because they would have never made that
kind of money in the podcasting game
podcasting is hard cable is easier
because you're gonna have a script to
read teleprompter 50 people handing you
a piece of paper and research and 17
facts on a piece of paper you don't have
that when you're independent this is why
when you see a guy like Joe Rogan
kicking everyone's ass he doesn't have a
research team when he go to his office
you know what it is it's him and another
guy let's build a number one show and
all these other podcasts you're watching
what the hell are these guys doing moral
of the story here's a moral of the story
that's getting me fired up you ready for
this you ready for this let's go hey
if
you talk to any presidential candidate
not that I'm going to be talking to any
of them but if we do you never know just
throwing it out there you know what the
question and the commitment we have
here's the question I want to get from
them
hey Mr presidential candidate yes
um out of nearly 200 countries worldwide
only two of them allow for big Pharma to
advertise which what are those it's New
Zealand and United States interesting
which is kind of strange and a lot of
American people are starting to ask the
question why is it that only one percent
of countries in the world allow for
pharmaceutical companies to advertise Us
in New Zealand are you trying to save
folks in Japan are dumb are you trying
to say folks in Germany are dumb or
Mexico or Canada or even some of these
socialist companies that you admire
countries that you admire Venezuela you
know how about China why don't they
allow big Pharma to advertise isn't it
deeply concerning to you well it is
what if moving forward are you willing
to agree as a president that if you
become a president you will no longer
allow big Pharma to advertise on cable
TV and if this candidate there's one
candidate that I know four fact would
say yes and he'd run with it you know
what his name is his initials are
okay do you know what happens if Trump
runs with this let me break it down for
you if 75 of cable is getting their
money from Big Pharma and they all
supported vaccine and they all supported
us taking the vaccine over and over and
over and over again
they said moving forward you can no
longer do especially you know why this
could happen today because this happened
after covet and people don't trust
Pharma today they don't trust CDC today
they don't trust the government today
and they don't trust the mainstream
media today the lowest it's ever been
they don't trust it today if the
president said you know what moving
forward guess what we're not doing this
no more big pharma's out this means 75
of mainstream media companies are gone
overnight wow overnight CBS ABC NBC CNN
ESPN CNN Fox go to Fox commercials MSNBC
their budget is gone so these guys that
they're able to pay them all this money
they're not paying them the money
Pfizer's paying them the money all these
big in pharmaceutical companies are
paying them now that they're not getting
the money they're going to go to the
talent and say listen man another paying
you six million dollars we kind of got
to bring that to one and a half million
what six million is what I've been
getting paid I've been living in this 10
million dollar house you want me to get
out of this house we can't pay you that
anymore bro we can't I'm going to leave
then it's gonna be well go go leave
We're not gonna go I'm gonna go to CBS
they also have the same problem I'm
going to call NBC they also have this
let me call my manager I'm going to call
my managers from WME hey Johnny he was
laid off yeah
so so so the moral of the story here is
all of the stuff that's going on uh
you're going to see what it's going to
go down to here's what it's going to go
down to it's going to go down to who can
sell who can perform who can get
eyeballs who can get subscribers who can
keep creating content that's exciting
sexy interesting who keeps recreating
themselves because those who don't this
dinosaur caveman model of how the Medias
ran protected by big Pharma will be
destroyed overnight if a courageous
president has the brass to say moving
forward big farmer can no longer
advertise that big brass Papa don't uh
don't you think like his life expectancy
is going to drop a little bit lower
because of Bigfoot big farmer you don't
play games with them bro I don't know if
anybody have you ever seen the movie
Michael Clayton I know it's a it's a
movie but these people have people
working for them that don't pat you're
going after trillions and trillions of
dollars you know what I mean you don't
think that's gonna piss people off in
that in that industry street so here's a
question isn't about pissing them off
the pissing them off is of course gonna
happen yeah yeah how many movies you got
like the Michael Clayton Aaron
Brockovich you know Michael Clayton
remember the movie back in the days
thank you for smoking we got you guys
going around talking about movie great
movie phenomenal movie Why smoking is
okay for you smoke is not very worried
and the guy acted so well the same guy
from Batman right he's the one guy that
played in Wonderland whatever his name
is yeah good-looking guy uh
yeah yeah yeah so so it's a great movie
but someone's got to have the audacity
to do it because if you don't look guys
let me let me let me read this story to
you check this out heart attacks at
record levels after pandemic this is the
telegraph story page 15. what do you
mean heart attacks at record level after
the pandemic so
what page is that on right page six okay
heart attacks at record level after the
pandemic compensation there you go okay
thank you
um so here we go record numbers of
post-pandemic heart attacks
hospitalizations exceeded 84 000 uh
cases in England for 20 21 2022 making a
7 000 case increase underlying delayed
uh detection concern says official data
a new uh NHS campaign pushes early uh
action urging individuals to dial 999
when encountering heart attack symptoms
like chest tightness and sweating aiming
for better survival odds emphasizing
Professor uh Nick Linker NHS National
Clinical Director for heart disease
every moment that passes during a heart
attack increases heart muscle damage
please call 999 so you have the best
chance to a full recovery a 250 million
pound NHS funding boost for winter with
plans to not for 900 extra bets seeks to
address pandemic including service
disruptions and higher heart related
deaths while heart Charities emphasize
the urgency of timely care okay this is
just in UK these reports are coming out
here you saw the story of Caleb White
another 17 year old kid number three
high school basketball player in Alabama
dies after collapsing on court we just
had LeBron's son went through that
brownie we were all looking forward to
the day for him to play with us and and
the the World Cup female soccer player
from I don't know Colombia or something
collapsed twice how many people on the
news they're doing the news and the lady
drops comedians dropping politically so
now we don't know what it is we want to
know what it is but what we do know
what's happened the last three years
people trust big Pharma less people
trust the governments let governments
plural worldwide everywhere governments
less people trust World Health
Organization less people trust NIH less
CDC less all of these guys less and all
people are saying is listen I'm sick and
tired of just being seen seen as the
sicker I am the more money you make off
of me the more hospital beds are filled
the more money you make off of me yeah
empty beds don't make hospitals money we
need hospitals to be full to make the
hospital money when you start looking at
it from this angle rather than the
incentive being healthy or you are the
better you do a couple years ago an
insurance company came up to us they had
a program called Vitality okay I don't
know if you remember this time or not
Vitality oh yeah yeah Hancock is a good
memory so Hancock you know what their
memory their their product was yeah I
remember that we'll sell you an
insurance policy and if you wear this
Fitbit year-round and the Fitbit reports
back to our insurance company that
you're moving your body and exercising
your cost of insurance is going to
decline every quarter or so what a
product you're incentivizing people to
not need their life insurance policy let
me say that again you're incentivizing
the insurance company is flat out
telling you listen man I want you to
live longer okay please exercise so you
can live longer so I don't have to pay
you the death benefit in case you die
and if you keep exercising and moving
your body I will charge you less for the
insurance policy that's what you call
Compassionate capitalism where you're
using it in a way to say listen let's
keep hospitals emptier I'm going to give
you know a certain incentive for keeping
people healthier you know you don't hear
Governors or presidents talking about
guys start reading some business books
start exercising stop eating at some of
these places that's fast food you don't
hear those conversations you know if I
told you right now a president that
talks about the Border you would say
Trump if I told you a president that
talks about the number one world crisis
in the world is white supremacy you
would say Biden if I told you the
biggest crisis in the world is climate
change you would think about AOC Greta
or some of these guys but if I told you
name me one political leader that talks
about go read some damn books go
exercise take cure your health stop
eating shitty food you can't think about
a candidate no you can't no well this is
the incentive program so going back to
the enemy is real but I think the other
side skeptical people are like listen
man it's about time we go address these
guys I'll just say one thing I can't
think of a candidate and that would be
RFK not I mean it was so like
fascinating to watch the debate or
whatever the potential debate that he
had with the guy Dr Peter Hotes meaning
you got you got RFK who's who actually
admitted to taking the vaccine but it
says it's okay to question the vaccine
especially the operation warp speed and
Rush down the pike and what's happening
with that but here you got this dude how
old is he 70 65 Jack Jack diesel working
out then you've got Dr Peter Hotes
vaccine Advocate I'm telling you under
that white coat it ain't looking good
fast food addict exactly so you know
ultimately what does it come down to are
you going to be proactive about your
health are you going to be reactive
hospitals you know what we call it
yesterday a hotel for sick people unless
those beds are not filled basically the
vacancy they're not making any freaking
money exactly so I mean what did we
learn during covet just take the jab
take the vaccine don't ask any questions
nobody was saying bro get the [__]
outside work out get some sun eat
healthy stay active sweat but that's the
mess but there's no money in that who
makes money the gyms okay Fitness
instructors that's awesome but that
ain't big Pharma that's not their
business model that's how they make
their money you know it's with sick
people you know you and I are in the
insurance business and Tom you're an
insurance executive I mean we can call
you an insurance executive it's you know
have you been a president and a CSO
insurance company I was adopted by the
industry so when questions when the
questions asked about life insurance how
to get even with the life insurance
company you know my statement always
don't cancel your policy yeah what do
you mean don't die don't cancer no no no
don't cancel your policy what does that
mean don't cancel your policy because
the insurance company banks on
eventually you canceling your policy
yeah and when you do that premium goes
to who the insurance company okay so but
if you keep your policy and you
eventually die they have to pay out so
if you want to get even with the
insurance company buy your policy never
cancel that is the wisest thing you can
do because what happens with insurance
companies is you buy an insurance policy
a 2008 crisis happens a covet happens
what's the first thing people cancel
insurance policy what they don't realize
the insurance policy you got you got it
when you were 33 years old healthy and
it was good you got to prove so you
prefer to lead you're paying cost of
insurance is nothing but a crisis
happened and now you canceled it say you
were paying 100 bucks a month I'm just
using basic math now you're 43 years old
okay you got a wife and three kids and
you're like I gotta go out there and get
an insurance policy well now you're
older you're sicker you're not healthier
now your insurance policy is no longer
100 bucks a month now you got to pay two
three four whatever the number is going
to be depending on based on your health
so but people cancel it if you keep it
you're going to be healthy we need more
policies that say look let's incentivize
people that don't use health insurance
let's give credit to people that take
care of their health give them a tax
incentive every year where you're not
going to the doctor all the time when
you are keeping a certain weight on your
body and all this stuff let's give
incentives for staying healthy if we
could do that we have a better Society
we can easily increase our life
expectancy we can easily increase our
lifestyle we can do those types of
things but those types of policies don't
make money exactly and Pat it's funny
you say that because you know being a
veteran just like you you I got my car
insurance through USAA and they have
this thing that you could add it's
called safe pilot so the app is tracking
no matter if you're driving Pat and you
pick up your phone it docks you if
you're talking like this if you're a
speaker so now I'm trained now to where
I'm like if it ain't important I'm not
on my phone 30 I get discount per month
because I'm not on my phone talking
driving and being unsafe ultimately
you're talking about rewarding people
who are driving safe or being healthy
and doing all that and obviously I won't
go here but obviously I can talk for
days about people canceling their life
insurance policies that's my business
model but especially if in your 30s 40s
50s even 60s
keep that policy as you get older it
gets way more expensive especially if
you're trying to qualify for insurance
yep let's go to the endorsement that Ron
DeSantis God which is a legendary
endorsement you should put this on the
wall by the way somewhere in his office
and he should brag about it at the uh uh
uh campaign anywhere he's going where
he's talking he should bring this up
here we go ready Hillary Clinton wow
says Rhonda Santos is pathetic and just
trying to get some attention Hillary
Clinton says something like that about
you that is an endorsement yes how I
would take it yes Hillary Clinton
criticized uh Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis describing his proposal to
Grant resident presidents uh more
control over the department of justice
justice as pathetic and attention
seeking during an MSNBC interview with
Rachel Maddow she commented he's
promising anything to try to get some
attention it's kind of pathetic isn't it
the sentence has previously questioned
the independence of agencies like the
doj stating you can't say that you're
independent and hands-off that that's
not the way the system is designed his
press secretary from this commitment to
ensuring uh accountability and Justice
and law enforcement agencies the
discussion also touched on the
Republican party's Embrace of partisan
policy politics within law enforcement
prompting Clinton to express worries
about democracy and the rule of law
particularly given the lingering
influence of trump uh Vinnie thoughts on
this I just like is it just me or and I
want to know from the from the people
and you guys too are you guys tired of
like this Hillary we couldn't get it
that nobody gives a damn what you're
saying and she just won't go away do you
know what I'm saying she was on The
Rachel Maddow Show and they were and
besides this one besides the Santas they
were laughing these two were laughing
the two of the biggest liars about Trump
and the indictments and how happy she is
meanwhile she is the biggest getting
away with cheating and murder person
I've ever met in my life and like like
when is enough going to be enough and
she just keeps popping out of the
woodwork and nobody just go away she
would love to run if there's any opening
she would do anything here's my question
why wouldn't you okay why would why why
isn't she running this time around why
isn't she going for the Gusto I'm with
her and all those bumpers why why isn't
she running oh how do you know she's not
are you sure what I'm saying to you is
never underestimate a person that since
they were in the womb they wanted to be
the president United States never she
looks at herself as the world leader she
looks at herself as an Emperor as a
president as the queen her identity is
that now whether you like it or not that
is her identity she's convinced she's
above you and everybody else and she
knows what's best to run the world
that's how she views herself she looks
at everybody as beneath them everybody
anybody and everybody she looks at
including her anybody she says yeah I'm
I'm Beneath You're beneath me I know
what's best that's how she views herself
when you're like that any opportunity so
the strategy would be if you go right
now run against Biden you're gonna look
like an idiot she wouldn't run right
like do what RFK that she's about that
she's better that's that's cheap stuff
that RFK people would do in her eyes
yeah in her eyes she's more strategic
behind closed doors get a couple favors
use the doj which you know she's you
know to eliminate some candidates and
then she see if she gets she gets in
there are certain people that are so
deceptive they should never ever count
them out on how they gain power she's
one of those people and the super
delegate game that she knows how to play
behind the scene which is sort of a
rigged part of the DNC and I go back to
2008 you could almost just change the
words here Hillary Clinton 2008 just
visualize this instead of pathetic
Barack Obama is inexperienced and just
trying to get some attention this has
been her Playbook yeah well last time
she said that that guy became the
president he did okay well I don't know
if that's necessarily going to be uh the
case this time with our friend uh
Governor DeSantis just to Circle back to
that no but it is her Playbook that's
how she works thanks Tom
um I just to Circle back to the whole
premise is this this is great marketing
campaign uh for DeSantis we all saw the
commercial uh about the trans family
that was leaving Florida for greener
pastures he should use that to his
Advantage yeah okay we you know
everything I've done in Florida so if
you're trying to win a Republican
primary what's more helpful to you than
going to battle with Hillary Clinton if
you're Ron DeSantis so I actually think
this is a net positive for him in the
Republican primary and his numbers have
been fading and fading and fading you
know it was six months ago he was neck
and neck with Trump now it's it's not
even close so maybe this helps did he
did he fire his marketing person and
hire a new person I think he fired his
uh Chief of Staff the third oh yeah it's
it's not it's not good it's not a good
look on what's going on over them by the
way in New Hampshire can you pull up New
Hampshire polls can you can you pull up
New Hampshire polls I think in New
Hampshire polls he's officially behind
Chris Christie in New Hampshire if you
guys haven't seen this uh uh pull this
up to see uh let's see if that shows up
or not and if you're standing behind
Chris Christie nobody can watch this
polls put that's a good point I didn't
even think about that very scientific
that's interesting polls put Christie's
second to Trump in New Hampshire as
DeSantis Fades yeah
oh it doesn't let you get there I'm
actually I would like to see where
DeSantis is in Iowa I'm not shocked that
Christy is doing well in the Northeast
everyone in New Hampshire New Jersey New
York they kind of they're they're
familiar with him he'll pull well there
I'd like to see what the stats are in
Iowa because that is the first state
correct
show that nine percent likely what would
you probably would know him to Christy
to the Republican only eight percent to
Chris okay let's go look at Iowa what's
Iowa look like do you have RCP real
clear politics
Robin I think I'll let you pull
everything
Real Clear Politics yeah election 20 up
at the top I would assume that DeSantis
is doing way better in Iowa than he's
doing in New Hampshire
okay punch in on that buddy National
National Trump said 54 Cent this is at
14.
6.7 Pence money has cleared Pence former
vice president what you highlighted it
he's lost he's only he's the only
candidate that's lost Twitter followers
in seven months you got Iowa where
you got Iowa where it's a little bit
closer than the national average or
DeSantis is at 17 Trump said 44 and then
and this is after this how recent is
this Adam how recent is this uh this is
this today ask ask Malik or here
go back to New Hampshire this is today
yeah and then all right so then DeSantis
so well DeSantis apparently is doing
better than Christy in New Hampshire and
not the shift gear so what Trump these
indictments that are happening Trump's
numbers are actually they they went up
correct they actually went up so my
thing is the left is doing because
apparently he can still run if even if
he's arrested or felon or whatever what
is their angle to boost them up like
this because they think he's easier to
beat than whoever would be behind him I
mean obviously look at the numbers
nobody's voting for anybody else why is
this show in New Hampshire DeSantis
ahead and that are all these articles
are saying that these are these are
compilation polls from Real Clear
Politics and what you're seeing is the
first poll of the week which correctly
is pointing out that there's a shift
going it might just be one pull what's
interesting let's see this general
election match-up how much do you trust
this Source Tom just high low Medium
real clear politics is 10 to 14 days
behind the actual momentum that's in the
market but they compile everything and
if you were to click through on them so
do you trust them or not
they've been more right than wrong okay
what point is we'll use this as a source
where's the general election
s
so it looks like it's a dead heat with
Biden Trump yeah 44-44 yep uh looks like
Biden is doing better than DeSantis 44
to 42. and then what is it it took the
time to see how Trump would do against
Kamala Harris 46-42 but uh here's what I
can guarantee I I'm going on the record
stating this it's going to be October
it's likely to be Trump Biden okay and
what we're going to hear from the news
is race is too close to call you know
it's going down to the wire right we got
to see what's going on in the three
Battleground States Pennsylvania
Michigan and Georgia and this stat right
here has Biden and Trump at a dead heat
18 months out and that just boggles not
even 18 months out what are we 14 months
out it just boggles my mind that like
still with everything that's happening
with crime border Ukraine that's just a
short list people are still like I still
you know I don't want somebody that's
going to rock the boat and they just
want this six senile perverted kid
sniffing like it drives me insane that
people still haven't I'm not woken up to
what's happening I'm not shy shocked
whatsoever everything I'm just saying
every election goes down to the wire so
if you're expecting something different
that's a definition I think if they when
if if it is him which it looks like it
is he should show up on an orange
jumpsuit and be like orange is the new
orange and that's how I would debate if
I was drunk
I do like just
just it's great
he's going to regardless
since that's what you're talking about
let's talk about what happened here uh
with the indictment let's go to Trump
faces 70 six and a half years in prison
yeah uh in Georgia 91 counts
717 and a half years overall man these
they think it's like a Biblical guy he
lives like to 700 years plus death
penalty uh uh uh so former president
Donald Trump could face up to 76 if he's
convicted and receives a maximum of all
sentences then 13 counts he faces the
indictment uh filed by Fulton County
Georgia district attorney Fanny Wills
late Monday night here at accounts one
violation of George's Rico racketeering
influencer by the way this was for the
mob up to 20 years five uh solicitations
or violation of Oath by a public office
or up to three years nine conspiracy to
commit impersonating a public officer 11
conspiracy to commit forgery in the
first degree 13 conspiracy to commit
false statement and writings conspiracy
to commit filings false statements
that's another five years conspiracy to
commit to forgery in the first degree
seven and a half years conspiracy
conspiracy commit false statements and
writings two and a half years filing
false documents 10 years solicitation of
violation of Oath by public officer
false statements of writing solicitation
of violation of Oath by public officer
another one false statements in writing
again hundreds so in addition he faced
136 years and 34 counts in New York case
450 years and 40 counts in the Miami
case oh my God 55 years and four counts
in the federal case in DC
and Trump could face up to 717 years in
prison the latter charge in DC also
includes the possibility of death
penalty pat first of all it's comical at
this point but you know what Trump
should have listened to Chuck Schumer
remember Chuck Schumer warned him the
Department of Justice has seven ways of
Sunday to get you and let's just all be
clear Trump didn't try to overturn an
election Pat he was just suspicious that
the left was trying to cheat again okay
they were cheating in 2020 with the
whole FBI like stopping the hunter Biden
story and all that stuff with Joe Biden
Hillary Clinton cheated in 2016 when she
tried to undermine the election with the
whole Russian collusion and you know
what pisses me off about out of this the
worst Pat is that the Republicans I'm
sick and tired of people like Kevin
McCarthy uh Jim Jordan Matt Gates all
they're doing is barking if you watch
all these Judiciary hearings from
anything from the indictments to covet
to everything they are the biggest
sitting there barking and saying they're
gonna do this and how many whistles have
to be blown how many whistleblowers how
many smoking guns need to be found Pat
till they actually do something nothing
nothing is going on and that's why it
keeps bringing back to the point that
they're all on the same team Republican
Democrat same same freaking team one
just barks doesn't bite and the other
one is getting away with murder and I
just want I hope that The Independents
out there are watching if you don't see
what's going on with Trump right now
you're either a sheep or you're like
you're just too dumb to understand
what's going on I I keep saying to my
theory Tom but you go first I'll give
mine after yours so when I look at this
remember we we broke down um who was it
Ellen Bragg in New York and how he had
inflated everything remember that Pat
we've done a podcast Alvin Brooke Alvin
Bragg
and the D.A New York and here's what's
happening here take away everything that
says solicitation and conspiracy
conspiracy says two guys were thinking
about it talking it over so let's don't
say they did it and solicitation there's
a time and a place for that that's
called Congress the only thing you see
here is that first count violation of
Georgia RICO Act so you actually did
something everything else here is just
stuffing the turkey with bread there's
nothing really here except that one big
count and they are attempting to make
everything seem better by adding up all
these years this would never happen if
you and me were indicted like this in
Georgia the 76 years would go down to a
year and a half for Rico if we were
convicted this is just this is fluff
they are fluffing and puffing up just
like Bragg did in New York city so when
people hear about this you just have to
realize just how political size this is
and what is really a count here and what
is really oh and also conspiracy
conspiracy conspiracy conspiracy
conspiracy seven of those two three
solicitations this is that's ridiculous
conspiracy and solicitation even if you
prove it people go okay so Tom and Pat
talked about doing something in the
insurance industry did they do it no but
it was conspiracy to commit but they
didn't actually do it all right well why
don't we give them both a 200 fine and
get them out of here that's what happens
in these things this is how long do you
think they've known they're going to be
doing this for a while oh this is time
this is on a calendar in somebody's
office hey on Thursday that's when we
need to do it but Tom honestly like you
you're sharp guy how long give me a
timeline have they known they're going
to be doing this for two years for a
year and a half for for one year for six
how long have they known they're going
to be doing this I would say probably a
year and a half because six months after
Biden's inauguration they knew he was
politically having trouble I'm guessing
probably on the January 7th yeah
[Music]
even before then because you had to
figure out that they were gonna go there
and protest I'd say a couple of days
before because then you had to have FBI
agents inside the capital outside
pushing people to make you become this
thing to have it come down okay so let
me ask you so these people that I've
been working on this for as long as you
say that yes yes who who are they loyal
to are they loyal to hear me out are
they loyal to
uh Biden are they loyal to Obamas are
they loyal to the party who who are they
loyal to for the country it's definitely
not the country who they destroying the
country we look we're looking big that's
the first time in the history of America
that this has ever happened with any
president then there's been a lot of
stuff that's happened in the past before
this is not something that we practice
to look this pathetic in front of the
world so who are they loyal to who's
their loyalty
I'm not saying this is the case but I
would hope that their loyalty especially
if they're prosecutors and judges and
doj that their loyalty would be to the
law okay what do you think their loyalty
is to Tom I I think they're loyal to the
Democratic party okay I agree it's two
district attorneys that have been put
out there and I don't think these DA's
know that they're being played history
is going to have their name do you think
they're not anybody do you think they're
more loyal to the Constitution to the
law or their political party the
constant what exactly the party so which
case are you talking about because
they're all wildly different no of which
case any case that they want to put this
guy away if you're talking Alvin Bragg
in New York or if you're talking the
Mar-A-Lago thing yeah I'm with you but
the Georgia thing I think is totally
different you have a governor Brian Kemp
you have the lieutenant governor what
was his name it's like katzenberg or
something like that these are
Republicans these were people that voted
for Trump you also have Mike Pence who
was the boot licking VP who is the
probably star witness in the January in
January 16th so I'm just I'm just saying
that there's a nuanced conversation here
I don't think Brian Kemp is law
okay so let's say that Brian Kemp was
even asked if Trump is the nominee will
you still vote for him he said yeah so
you're right he did say if Trump's the
nominee I'm still going to be voting for
him Mike Pence is a different story if
Mike Pence is truly about the
constitution in America you know what
would happen if Mike Mike Pence was
really that
his followership and popularity would go
to the roof but it hasn't it hasn't from
anybody no okay so so then here's
becomes the motive becomes
we want to get rid of this guy because
he's going to come in and drain the
swamp and guess what let's eliminate him
okay this is even the Georgia thing it
isn't anything that Clinton's and others
haven't done in the past before okay but
the only thing is it was on tape that's
the whole thing so no doubt I mean I'm
sure the buttons was on tape saying if
the prosecutor doesn't do this and it's
the guy that his kid was getting money
from the back and he's still our
president United States and no one so so
to compare Biden stuff to Trump it's not
even a comparison well there are even
Nixon the Watergate tables yeah I mean
that's how they get you here's where I'm
going with it the point I'm trying to
make is the following point if they've
known for a while Tom that they're going
to be doing this okay if they've known
for a while Adam I want you to think and
play The Devil's Advocate here sure let
you so what percentage do you think
that the people who are on the inside
that know these things are coming and
it's time because it's time perfectly I
was telling it to Russell Brand
yesterday when I was on the show I said
uh you know the whole thing how every
time Biden got in trouble the exact next
day Trump gets indicted three four times
it's the same exact day you have to be a
dummy naive oblivious or like you're
happy they're doing that to say no
there's no chance this is accidental I
run no [__] it's happened many times
okay the timing is weird the timing is
weird so do you think the guys that know
they're writing this up to destroy Trump
do you think by any chance they've
spoken to DeSantis and knew some about
it
I would say they've spoken to Newsome at
DeSantis knows
I would you would say they've spoken to
Newsom but the scientist knows what I'm
saying is I think I think there's been
like straight up conversations but I
think they would have probably worked to
flow it to the Santos go deeper like
what kind of conversations you're saying
oh I think it's it's very subtle
Converse I think it's it's this kind of
a conversation let me kind of unpack it
for you make a role play so so so so you
got you got these guys that are doing it
yeah the people on the left know so
person on the left that say you know
maybe a leader or you know exactly I'll
read this here in a minute with Natalie
Ford those keep and scored 3 1700 bite
in the midst laptop 318 trumpet died mid
news six eight FBI doc alleges Biden
bribe six nine indictment seven twenty
six hundred please deal collapse of 727
in debt and 731 Devin Archer testified
eight one there's four times back and
then new one go to the bottom one on
what she's got okay eight nine one Biden
bank records release 811 doj did their
special account so we can go on and on
and on and on uh with these types of
things that's happening but here's where
I'm going so they know hey guys we're
about to drop the bomb and we're gonna
destroy this guy he will never have a
career in politics he'll be done and
he'll spend the rest of his life in jail
I'm talking about Trump here yeah yeah
I'm talking I'm talking
we're about to do this to Trump great
got it so a couple of the guys say hey
you know what I want you to do what
I'll give you bone okay go whisper to
your guy run
that don't worry about Trump he's not
going to be there at the end
it's his position
go whisper this to him
you think so yeah just go whisper to him
or indirectly well listen don't ever
tell the scientists I don't want him to
know it's a sign of what go tell him
because you know in that dirty World
whatever you say don't tell they go tell
it these are dirty people right some of
them that are in the dark sides of
politics
so then a guy comes up and says hey you
mean all of them so I'm not saying all
of them I'm not saying all of them I
actually do believe there are some good
Statesmen out there it's very hard to be
a good Statesman you have to realize in
every space there's dirty people and
there are states when I'm convinced
there's plenty of Statesmen there too
but it's very hard to stay a true
statement over time so then one guy
comes hey uh listen
um you talk to one of the sentences
right hand guys so look it's between us
I want to whisper this too but please
don't say anybody that I said this to
you here's what they're going to be
doing to Trump so it's going to be an
open
you know run for him he's pretty much
going to be the candidate he has to lose
it to not be the nominee oh really yes
then they come back and they say hey
here's the news guess what take our time
we're launching the campaign we don't
have to be as aggressive going out there
wait
then defend him and say the fact that
the OJ is going after him then defend
him that this is not the right way to do
because you'll seem like a hero and
you're going to gain the mega crowd
what are the chances that that kind of a
conversation has had where the news has
been given to him to say this is your
opening because he's not going to be
there at the end uh
what are the chances that a conversation
possible I would say all these types of
shady conversations are happening no
doubt I what I will say so I'll agree
with you what I will see if those
conversations did take place you know
follow the money follow the numbers it's
not helping uh the sentence campaign no
but his numbers are Plumbing but don't
you think that's that's not that's not
on them dude that's on him yeah but
that's correct not on that's not because
you have to have the talent to get the
eyeballs and if you can't sell the dream
of why you ought to be the candidate and
you're just talking logical stuff and
it's just policy policy policy policy
policy you can you can't get the people
then I'll go deeper if there is that
conversation happening which I think
maybe we'll see I think they're
Whispering it to everybody here at Pence
don't drop out of the race this is what
may happen but hey Governor Christie
stay in this thing hey Tim Scott you
could be the first black Republican boom
hey Nikki Haley I don't think they're
just going to put all their chips on to
Santa if that's conversations are
happening but they're really and I'm I'm
going even further back those guys are
not a threat though no not at all that's
what I'm saying so Pat why would the
Democratic party want to do all this to
Trump and say Hey Ron you're gonna
you're gonna be that guy because they
know they could easily be wrong because
he hasn't done [__] Biden Trump is the
threat Trump is the threat and if you
don't see the cheating if we were all
racing on Monday Pat and on Sunday I
know that you're my only challenge it's
me I know and I know that you're faster
than me you're you're showing if I knew
cops and like maybe a judge I'm like hey
go go arrest Pat I'm gonna go set him up
and that's cheating they're cheating
they're taking the legs out of the
number one guy because they want Ron do
they want if it's Biden you're saying
that Rhonda Santos uh that Biden could
easily beat Ron I think easily he'll be
doing all right that's fully disagree
with you don't think Joe Biden's good
what if Ron DeSantis was the candidate I
think he would whip up on Joe Biden I
don't think so I don't I think that's
why he's vibrant he's not exactly the
most the best marketer but you're going
against Joe Biden who's not a marketer
at all I fully disagree I think DeSantis
would whoop up on Biden then why are
they why are they popping why are they
getting rid of trump because DeSantis is
the next guy they're just getting rid of
trump because they want to get rid of
trump regardless of who's next but as a
plan you would have to know that the
number two guys gonna you know I mean
they're gonna have to go against that's
a better fight for them is this Santa's
is that what you're saying like that's a
that's a look if you're looking at the
general election matchups what you just
talked about 10 minutes ago Biden and
Trump are still at a dead heat I have
and buying into santis are within two
points I want to believe what you're
saying Adam I want to believe what
you're saying but I'm not convinced uh
DeSantis is going to beat vivec I'm not
convinced DeSantis is going to be able
to take Vivek out I think vivec is
um is is and by the way we're going to
learn a lot about the debate the first
debate that's coming up on stage we
don't know if Trump's going to be there
or not when is it most likely uh uh it's
coming up like in a week or something
23rd we don't even know if uh Trump's
going to be on stage or not but if Vivek
comes out and he puts on a show and all
of a sudden you see the santis drops off
and Vivek goes up you're gonna be like
wait what just happened here that's
pretty wild that's number one when I say
one thing about Vivek I'll say that guy
is an absolute Beast he's an absolute
stud but you're gonna say what his
religion Hindu that we're not ready
running as a republican Christian
Evangelical you're telling me they're
going to vote for a brown Hindu guy
we'll see about that okay all right if
he was running as a Democrat that guy
would be the next Obama no doubt vivac
good Plumbing good point by the way by
the way let's see okay let's see you
have to still be able to sell the dream
I think he's in the scientist doesn't
know hasn't shown yet how to sell the
dream he sounds like a guy that's
talking to you that there's an element
of I'm smarter than you and I'm better
than you and trust me just you know I
know and that doesn't relate a little
Hillary Clinton asked yes a little bit
it's just upon you trust it's the one
you trust more it's a it's a guy that I
actually think he's got solid characters
and values I think he's a good guy I
think he's a good husband good father
but he's also been wanting to be a
president since the womb he's been
wanting to be president for a long time
I put those two I don't think Trump's
been wanting to be a president since day
one I think RFK just wanted to be his
father's son and spend time with his dad
and his heartbroken devastated 14 years
of being addicted to drugs from 28 to 42
he's lived a hard life the guys lived a
very weird life not saying he doesn't
have the additional stuff where I'm
going with this is the following
you know if if you truly are thinking
the centers would do better than Biden
if you truly think the centers would do
better against Biden
why why are you eliminating Trump as a
candidate
if if Democrats are more straight
strategic than the right why not wait
to go after Trump if he's not even a
candidate he's gonna he's gonna be gone
why do you care about him so much
if you think well I think the center is
going to be to Biden no problem all this
stuff well then you know no problem
if you really think that's it then let
Trump be the candidate because you know
you're going to be Trump
these are very the Democrats you I
respect them so how United that group is
the level of unity that the Dems have
over Republican Republicans compete
against each other Democrats are like
nah man I can't stand you I hate you
you're the worst human being in the
world but what are your Democrat we're
on the same page bro we're going to be
all right that's how United they are on
their party I'll give you a little
feedback on the Democratic party uh
they're just whoever's leading in the
polls they'll try to dismantle it's
Trump it's the scientist they'll go on
and so forth I think if you're a
Democrat right now you are about to run
literally the worst polling president
you've possibly ever run ever okay so
Biden 75 of Democrats are like bro don't
do it bro don't do it but he's doing it
and they're all gonna coalesce and get
in line but nobody's excited about Biden
and uh well I think it's gonna be a [__]
he did try to excite somebody but it
didn't work for him so former Senator
told Biden he'd kicked the [__] out of
him then VP for getting handsy with his
wife if you want to get this video ready
by the way former Senator Scott Brown
recounted a threat he made to President
Joe Biden after an alleged incident 2010
when Biden got too close to Brown's wife
Brown stated I told him I'd kick the
[__] out of him uh beat it uh be and
then I told him to stop the incident
took place during uh Brown swearing
ceremony with photographs capturing
Biden's hand position near Brown's
wife's posterior what poster is like
butt is that what that means anger
Outburst Brown also criticized Biden's
well-known touchy Behavior mentioning an
incident where actress Eva Longoria had
to guide Biden's hands away from her
breasts you can show that clip as well
White House from screaming in June but
play this clip and then play to the
podcast of him saying this with TMZ go
for it just a clip
rap sees it I don't know if I know well
what do I watch his right arm boom boom
boom boom I literally can't see his arm
listen I could see it at him
literally can't see his arm no I see
three times he tapped her butt oh I mean
why would the guy lie why is he lying
why she thinks she's okay so pause and
go to go through what he said on the
podcast if you have it Rob I don't know
if you do or not okay let's play this
one here go for it
air sniffing Gail or handy with Gail or
did I imagine yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
told him I'd kick the [__]
I told him to stop so yes I think people
are irked out about all the hair
sniffing and things then we went
overseas and he especially took a long
inhale and I think women are skeeved out
by that that stuff stuff and and you
know he's not a good guy oh you know him
I mean listen he's he's he's I I did
know him I I spent quite a bit of time
with him I I enjoy this company but
that's not Joe Biden he is this you we
all know the signs Mike yeah my uh you
know we all know people who have
dementia and and I have the beginning of
Alzheimer's and and you know he's got it
I mean it's the walk it's the way he's
mumbling his anger outburst and you know
it's it's a shame uh that we can't do
better as I said uh in this great
country but you know a lot of people
don't want to run because of everything
you're seeing now yeah hey you know I
might be imagining this but did you you
when you were on the herald radio with
us probably seven years ago when you got
sworn in as Senator was he like hair
sniffing Gail or handy with Gail or did
I imagine yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
told him yeah okay but but is it just
boggles my mind that it's just okay like
he's been doing it forever now that he's
old people are just like Eva Longoria
video if you can find it go for it you
know what I mean no pets like like is it
unbelievable that he's been getting away
with it forever how many videos this
one's awkward all right let me see him
all right this one's Awkward watch this
watch what she does go watch this one
he's he just hit the side nipple look at
that yeah he's shopping he's shopping
for cantaloupe sir guys I don't know no
no this is to me can I be honest with
you go ahead this is kind of weak
honestly I think he should step his game
up I like presidents that grab him by
the [__] okay I got you don't don't
half-ass these hugs just go all in show
me one video go for it show me one I'm
actually not kidding no oh Clinton yeah
listen if I'm married to Hillary Clinton
and some young intern who's of age and
consensual wants to in the White House
go ahead buddy you want to grab him by
the woo let's go for it yeah but if
Biden should step his game up stop
[__] half-assing and maybe touching a
derriere
sleepy ass Joe grab a [__] titty be a
man I'm your podcast
by the way welcome to the South castle
Yeah
Adam's crazy all jokes aside though how
many videos there dude there's
compilations of him not only grabbing
women like this sniffing kids touching
kids young 13 year old girls like this
hold on live on camera in the white
house while the vice president not
enough and he needs to do more I'm being
serious he's touching and smelling
children at him yeah the kids gets away
with it and he gets away with it bro
like that's that just shows you when
people are like these Elites they're not
protected there's no pedophilia the guy
is on camera smelling and clutching
girls that are looking like look at that
girl that that one photo right there uh
Rob the one look at that like if and
look at the father doesn't give a [__]
Pat look at what this I want to find
this girl and interview her excuse me
what did you feel when Joe Biden was
smelling you when you were 14 years old
it's disgusting and if anything that his
his daughter but Rob his daughter wrote
in that uh in her diary that they found
at the Airbnb by the way the dumbest
family ever Hunter leaves laptops in
repair shops and Hunter uh Joe Biden's
daughter left her diary at an Airbnb
then just hold on the project Veritas
people uh they had it you know what she
said my father was taking baths and
showers with me at an inappropriate age
what does that say to you Adam he's a
disgusting old man but guess what oh he
has dementia oh it's old Joe oh he's a
grandfather he's cute no it's disgusting
bro let me tell you something go ahead
how many politicians have you met in
your life
um the one a couple I'll say no you've
met way more than three okay let me tell
you something go ahead Adam there's a
something that all politicians do and
that is they say get out there shake
some hands and kiss some babies we all
know that they all do it now the problem
with Joe these days is that he's shaking
babies and kissing hands he's a little
dementia he doesn't know which one's
going on but they all do it bro if you
want to freeze frame you taking a
picture with a kid yeah it's always
going to look weird so anytime that you
want to make up a story you'll find no
doubt so is he creepy yes is Trump
creepy for sure are they all [__]
doing weird stuff for sure time so be be
an equal opportunity okay and call him
wait wait time out there is no way in
hell you are going to compare any other
random politician that who the hell has
a compilation of of what he's done in
the White House
kissing babies and saying hi and waving
and [__] no other president in the
history of presidents has that much
footage of him smelling little kids
period or rubbing on people's nipples
how much have you partied with Hunter
Biden be honest I have never parted with
them I tried but you never relaxed no
but that the kid stuff is disgusting I'm
sorry there's a there's a there's a
couple Lots will sit right there back
and forth there's a couple things to be
thinking about
um anytime you have a reputation of
overly uh being done it's it's pretty
real you can't think of a lot of stories
of politicians kissing babies and
anyone's use it to be as creepy as this
guy does it just very very good name
told me I'm with you there as in regards
to Trump and creepy Trump and creep you
want to call him player you're going to
call him a Salesman you want to call
them all that stuff totally fine you
want to call them is that businesses go
bankrupt totally fine creepy is not a
word that's going to catch on with him
um this is a guy that's a player like
Biden's not a player Trump is a real
life player he's had a lot of beautiful
women you can criticize criticize him
there all day long however there is
somebody that doesn't like to be courted
doesn't like stocking she's not a fan of
it okay at all okay she wants to be a
leader and you can't flirt with her
because
she sees that as stalking okay so today
we're going to talk about Rachel Ziegler
oh God who got backlash she's supposed
to be the next snow white she got
backlash
which could ruin Disney's show remake
Snow White okay let's read this and Rob
if you can get the clip ready uh of the
second one the one I tweeted a matter of
fact just go on my Twitter account and
you'll see the one that I have and and
just put that one up there you were just
on it right now okay so I'll read it
Rachel zegler
critical remarks regarding the upcoming
live-action Snow White remake have
triggered concerns about potential
damage to ticket sales the 22 year old
actress faced backlash for negative
views on the original 1937 film and the
prince character which she labeled a
stalker branding expert warns that
Ziegler comments could impact the film's
reception she has been accused of
gaslighting and dubbed a fake feminist
Disney faces challenges of managing Snow
White's portrayal and controlling actors
statements to prevent negative effects
on ticket sales despite Rachel zegner's
playing the lead role experts suggests
that Disney executive might need to
reconsider her suitability for promoting
the film so play this clip if you may
just listen to what she says she just
sounds bitter and angry go for it
the original cartoon came out in 19
years what a big focus on her love story
with a guy who literally stalks her
weird weird so we didn't do that this
time so no prints or a different kind of
Prince we have a different approach to
what I'm sure a lot of people will
assume is a love story just because like
we cast a guy in the movie great dude
um it's uh one of those things that I
think everyone's gonna have their
assumptions about what it's actually
going to be but uh it's really not about
the love story at all which is really
really wonderful and whether or not she
finds love along the way is anybody's
guess until 2024.
um all of Andrew scenes could get cut
who knows it's Hollywood baby right
where the hell are you to say all of
Andrews could get cut like who are you
oh my God are you Disney are you running
can you go back to the tweet on what I
told Bob Iger can you go back to that
here's what I told Bob I said I'm
curious Bob don't you think messages
like this is why Disney keeps having box
office flops I've read your book and I
have it's a phenomenal book it's right
over things called great book I had an
entire company read the book you're a
smart CEO I'm not sure I'm convinced
you're okay with this
you're losing generation of loyal
viewers when you think about Snow White
honestly what is the premise what is the
story it's a story it's a love story a
dream for a girl to grow up in a man
falls in love I mean the plot is about
well Prince Charming show up and then
after she says that she gets a bunch of
backlash play about 45 seconds of this
she actually cries if you can get to
that part and then I want to hear from
you there's a part that she gets
emotional like uh people are she said
death threats I don't know which dwarf
gave you death threat but she's saying
she's getting death threat sleep play
from right there you know that's your
age that's death to her career press
play go ahead
actually just played from the beginning
we just won't play the whole thing
and Pat well yeah while it's loaded
she's being censored now yeah yeah
exactly and Pat while it's loading then
guess what it's not the Snow White movie
then name it a different movie leave
Snow White alone yeah he's totally fine
go go ahead before the sink a place for
us
taken out of context and I know that at
this point I can't really stop people
from doing that because of course that's
what my whole existence on the Internet
is it's just me being taken out of
context and
stuff which is fine that's what I signed
up for
um but I never wanted to come off it
would be ungrateful for the
opportunities I have when I say that
this has been the biggest adjustment of
my life like understanding the way my
life operates now being who I am and the
things that I've been so fortunate to
make it comes with so much
ground so much ground that I never
thought I would be able to cover and
that people think I'm doing poorly and
other people think I'm doing gracefully
and I don't think I'm doing it at all
so
that it's hard
you can pause it right here I will tell
you this for I Love The Way She
communicates she's a freaking great
communicator words like ability to talk
fantastic obviously she's very
attractive very cute but her her Vibes
her eliteness her like I know what's
right and you don't and now you want to
apologize bro this is how the world
works when you get on social media we
are at our event at the insurance
conference what was the format it was a
debate format
debated each other you know what
everybody was asking me questions should
I say this should I say that here's what
I told everybody you can say that
but if you say that be ready that he's
gonna come for you yeah and she's going
to come after you do not be offended if
they come and say this about you like
well no no that's not fair I said no I'm
not telling you that all I'm saying to
you is that's how this thing works in
the world if you talk [__] it's going to
come back I tell my kids hey man you
talk [__] that guy hits you of course
he's gonna hit you there's something
called cause and effect we don't just
sit around and say okay yeah we grew up
watching this movie called Snow White in
all these other countries and all of a
sudden you show up and we have to
eliminate all the memories of these
young girls who grew up wanting to have
an experience like that and you're the
almighty and this guy that started a
company many years before you did who's
given you a job you want to trash that
Legacy that company that now Disney is
screwed up the last five years trying to
please a small percentage of minorities
in America that are bitching and whining
all the time while the majority is quiet
going about their business and raising
their families and we have to lift
listen to those guys crying all the damn
time yeah we're sick of it we're sick of
this [__] this is what you're
getting to the more you do this Disney
Iger
what is this girl's name Rachel Rachel
zegler Ziegler whatever her name is yes
this is exactly the backlash you're
going to get from parents who have kids
who are your customers you're supposed
to win parents over you're talking to
kids the parents pay for the tickets you
have to be a dummy as a marketer to be
if I'm Bob Iger you know what we're
doing emergency meeting we're putting
Snow White on hold for two years and
guess what pay your couple million bucks
go away we're going to bring another
person to play this role because you
just screwed this thing up and whoever
comes next you know the guy that uh one
of the things about Hollywood actors
that are not on social media you're
always like how come they're not on
social media and then some of the guys
that are professional I don't know who
did King Arthur who's the guy that
played King Arthur I don't know what his
name is he's a great actor if you type
in King Arthur movie what is this guy's
name um uh that guy right there what is
that guy from um what is his name very
good looking guy uh key man if you guys
can't go a little Lord you'll see it
right there right there right there that
guy right there on the bike gang uh no
that's not it man there's another King
Arthur movie young guy I could make a
joke right now maybe if he was on social
media we know his name well well no but
the point is they asked him they said
why are you not on social media and he
said that's intentional because it ruins
the art right yeah if you're an actor
and you're playing somebody that you
want us to right there that guy right
there Charlie human
yeah and he's doing that interview Sons
of Anarchy you know what I'm sitting I'm
like you know what I can't agree with
you on what you're saying listen Mrs
actress you want to get out there and
play real for us to believe you're that
person Will Ferrell is screwed for the
rest of his life if Will Ferrell plays a
serious movie I can't take him seriously
I can't take him seriously that's who
you are it's done yeah there's a reason
why the girl that played Exorcist who
walked backwards never got another movie
ever again ever there's a reason why the
Dirty Dancing when the girl got a nose
job we want the girl with the bigger
nose I love it we don't want the girl
with the smaller nose you ruined your
career we want that group right so we we
have a love affair with a role when
you're playing a movie you take that
innocence away you screw the whole thing
up for us so do you think Pat that that
they like basically told her to have
that actually because yo that's her
that's the story I don't think Baba is
okay with you you don't think because
that's the storyline though
that's okay but Bob Iger there's no way
Bob Iger is very very smart he is very
very smart he's not a he's not a
republican but he's also not a Democrat
when covet first happened he was helping
Newsom out with covet issues that was
going on because Disneyland is there and
Disney World is over here when Newsome
made a decision on shutting down all the
parks all of a sudden Iger said dude I'm
off this board and helping you out he
left Newsome so that is a call out to
Newsom saying dude your policies are
ruining jobs bro while this other guy
named DeSantis is keeping my Park open
you're screwing it up for me to I
believe he's a logical guy now he's got
a feud with Newsome over here with the
Santos over here I think he has logic I
think he can reason I think he's the
type of guy that could one debut good
presidential candidate so he knows this
is not a good thing he knows it okay
there's no way he's sitting around
saying I don't know why we're doing this
let me give you some feedback if I can
uh no I don't think that she was
I think this is genuinely she's a
product of the her times she's a product
of her environment here's a 22 year old
what mixed girl whatever yeah Latina I
don't know what she is whatever cute
girl whatever all good but she's a
product of her environment she's been
raised in a fem-centric girl boss the
future is female world I don't blame her
for any of this but there's a deeper
story here let me tell you something so
I had to go like watch a little clip of
Snow White read a little bio of Snow
White because I haven't read it in 30
freaking years okay here's actually the
story here and it's so funny how she's
making the creepy guy the the the enemy
uh
lo and behold the king uh the wife died
and he got a uh it was remarried to the
wicked stepmother she became the new
Queen do you recall this yes and this
wicked vindictive [__] thought that
Snow White was too pretty so what did
she do Tony yes
yeah are you looking at some big [__]
inside Joker inside joke so mirror
mirror on the wall who's the fairest of
the wall the mirror said Snow White is
and yeah so the stepmother the Queen the
wicked stepmother was like ah ah we
gotta kill that [__] enter hero number
one she calls on the Huntsman to go kill
snow white out in the forest in the
woods the Huntsman the man says no I'm
not killing this young beautiful girl
I'm gonna set her free so she goes free
so the Queen the vindictive murderous
[__] was the one that wanted to kill
Snow White Boom the Huntsman steps up
doesn't kill the girl okay almost like
the Hound yeah in um Game of Thrones
okay so hero number one so she's running
around in the woods she runs around and
finds what not one not two not five
seven seven little people because don't
call him towards now forget it oh your
ass will get canceled yeah so they're
sleepy there's Dopey there's grumpy
there's drug addict whatever's going on
there they're doing that they take her
in they're whistling while they work
that's a crazy concept they're working
their ass off they're in the mind they
take care of this girl enter seven more
Heroes taking care of the girl what
happens is this vindictive Queen finds
out she's still alive gives her a
poisonous Apple to eat she ends up dying
enter the third hero the [__] Prince
that shows up he's like who's this
beautiful dead girl I feel so bad for
her let me see if I can use my princely
charm and revive this dead chick okay so
he shows up saves her freaking life AKA
a stalker okay long story short she
comes back to life insert her she
becomes the queen happy ending all good
so I ask you this who's the bad guy in
the story The [__] the girl [__]
Queen okay who are the good guys in the
story The Huntsman that spared her life
the Seven Dwarves that took this
homeless chicken let her live with them
yeah and the freaking Prince that
literally saved her life and made her a
queen so what's the biggest theme Here
is that there's this Femme Centric
anti-men uh Mantra going on here but at
the end of the day here's what's going
to happen to this young lady she's
either going to come to the realization
that she's actually going to fall in
love with a real man much less a [__]
Prince if she can find one and like
Prince Harry and Meghan Markle who's
complaining about being a princess
that's a whole other conversation or she
can go down the Chelsea Handler I'm a
feminist boss babe I Don't Need No Man
mentality so the choice is yours young
beautiful girl
um Rachel zegler so uh the last thing
I'll say to this is okay the there's
been backlash about
um black girls playing white roles you
know what uh there was a black girl that
played Ariel The Little Mermaid whatever
all good I think Peter Pan they're
coming out in the movie Tinkerbell is
gonna be a black girl I don't really
care I mean I it'd be weird if a white
dude played Black Panther whatever but
what I have a problem with is
like Bradley Cooper playing Martin
Luther King exactly so okay it's a
little weird I don't really care what I
don't like is the historical
inaccuracies
now a white girl is going to play
Pocahontas that just didn't happen she
was a Native American by the way where
did Sleeping Beauty actually take place
it took place in Germany in the 1800s
how many black chicks are running around
there okay so just like Pinocchio
happened in Italy uh Cinderella Beauty
and the Beast Sleeping Beauty all
happened in France sorry Snow White was
in Germany so it's just historically
inaccurate so if you want to whitewash
history and do all that that's fine but
let me let me give the the the the the
bigger picture here what I do think is
is a great part of what Snow White is
about is actually there's a bigger
there's a bigger thing here is that the
world is a is a wild crazy place there's
good and there's evil you've got the
wicked poisoning okay you've got the
good man that's coming to save you
um there's a story about death being a
part of life she died she came back to
life she was revolved shout out to my
boy Jesus
um so is marriage so is love so is
Vanity looking in a mirror so is beauty
so is jealousy so his vindictiveness
there's a there's a there's a there's a
lot of things here that you don't really
recognize as a kid and you recognize as
adult but at the end there was a happy
ending what we say around here is the
future looks bright so shout out to Snow
White and what she's doing so in other
words Today's Show is sponsored by the
Snow White and the missing dwarf that's
coming out here soon in the next six
months uh thank you for Disney for this
uh sponsorship go ahead so you you would
so Adam like Rachel's Rachel Ziegler is
her name again she's the type of chick
that if God forbid she like OD'd or
something and died and the EMT showed up
they gave her mouth to mouth and she
woke up she'd be like that piece of [__]
right was trying to rape me it's like no
[__] I gave you I'll save my life yeah
so she's that type of girl but this is I
I mean by the way you did your Snow
White research I don't give a [__] what
anybody I did you were up last night
first time in 30 years
yours but yeah it's just I'm really
upset that it's that the biggest theme
Here is that it's anti-met and she
called him a stalker he literally saved
her life While She Was Dead yeah the
seven dwarves took her this homeless
chicken the Huntsman stared as prepared
his life but she because of the
environment she's been raised in all she
could see is that men are the stalker
men are toxic men are weird they were
the heroes in the story The Queen was
the villain so recognize that Rachel but
but
how many like this Disney is just not
learning their lesson bro from the from
the the kids stuff to that stuff to to
changing stories and stuff like are they
what how are they doing like stock wise
are they are they going down all this
work [__] isn't working go to go to one
year go to school yeah like Adam don't
you think no rap go back to where you
were at just go to one year Disney was
the first stop I ever won they're not
doing great
oh it's taking you there when you do
yeah okay got it well pal I'll tell you
what I'll tell you what it is right now
like aren't they gonna learn their
lessons there you go it's down yeah from
120 maybe go five years let's see what
it's like at five years down big five
years yeah five years yeah that's down
[__] it's the lowest it's been in five
years yes boy that's the right that's
the right of a lifetime so Pat when are
you when are you gonna learn your lesson
learn your lesson well listen Bob
shapeac to be fair uh was not a good CEO
okay he was a hardcore woke CEO that
Disney had that they were co-ceos
together I think Bob is the right guy
that can help this thing I really think
he has the ability to reason he was if
he's able to convince jobs to sell
convince Lucas to sell do you know what
brands this guy bought what Bob iger's
done in his resume there's not many
people maybe no one's ever done this
before this guy is maybe the biggest
power broker of the last 30 years I mean
this guy's not a joke on what he's done
in media he's one of the biggest power
Brokers in the world I am optimistic
that unless if they got some stuff on
him that they're controlling him I'm
optimistic that behind closers he's
gonna say listen guys this is too much
we got to cut the scrap this is too much
and his ESPN division just very smartly
got into OBS trying to save the division
on on Celebrity here celebrities don't
understand like this young actress that
Fame may give you a platform but it
doesn't give you credibility or make you
smart and often when you open your mouth
you show that you are not credible and
not smart and you can go through life as
a celebrity saying anything you want
about the conservative side of the
street you know what I mean pbd yeah and
there's no unaccountability for it no
accountability for it so you get
accustomed to popping your mouth off and
there's no accountability and all of a
sudden you go off rails at the presser
for your movie coming out that tens of
millions hundreds of millions of dollars
have been spent on it and you about to
find that you have entered fafo level
10. and welcome welcome
to me it's that simple you don't have
any accountability for opening your
mouth you pop off all the time and now
you do hear WeMo and you find out Fame
give you a platform it didn't make you
smart switch did you see it send me a
photo this is seven it's it's snow white
did you you see what the Seven Dwarfs
look like
there's seven little look at that little
but yeah but look at them those are the
those are the dwarfs is it not for the
new movie is this the movie Rob because
I know I know there was a big
controversy about Disney's live oh this
is a live action that's their live
action those are the dwarfs wait a
minute is this Woodstock that guy looks
six four on the back I was about to say
the last guy's about six four six five
that's a diverse Snow White remake
Rob Google that that's just that's the
Seven Dwarfs live action there that's
them and there was like I'm just happy
they're all men
Disney's live-action Snow White takes
walking they're really writing that's
his Library live action is those that's
the dwarves wow that guy is six well
look I mean here's here's what you have
to realize I mean when it comes down to
parents have to want to take their kids
to these movies yeah it's that simple
to the movies and if they do you you
prove your point okay it's working but
guess what the last five movies of yours
have been absolute box office flops not
one movie not two movies not three
movies now I'm doing pull on a LeBron
here not four movies five two movies
have been flops bro five movies have
been flops and you're Disney they're not
supposed to happen to you right five
moves being flops anyways let's hit a
couple other stores here before we wrap
up
uh one of the stories I do want to touch
on is do we want to go with this one uh
let me see which one I want to go to we
got a couple good ones you guys let's
pick one of them do you want to do the
market in Topanga do you want to do
Anheuser-Busch conversation we had with
them or do you want to do stay home dads
ESG or what the the CIA oversees China
what they said about America and then
we'll wrap it up with Armenian Genocide
which one do you want to go with now
pick one of them Tom you pick it I think
it's important to get to Armenia that's
an important message okay so but we'll
do that we're gonna do that no matter
why Pat okay let's talk a while so go on
later yeah why don't we go to Hawaii
let's talk about Hawaii okay so why
don't you lead the way with Hawaii I'll
lead the way with Hawaiian and me and
Rob were talking about this beforehand I
mean you know you know God absolute
tragic event I literally prayed last
night for them 100 I think that the
death toll Pat hit 100 a thousand people
they don't know where they are uh 111
people now 111 people that I think I
think there was 100 missing but they
don't know where a thousand other people
are you know you know our hearts go out
to them uh 5.5 billion dollars in damage
an entire neighborhood full of children
that died and here's the thing going
back to Biden Pat They asked them the
day that it happened they're like hey
press president the president of the
United States what do you have to say
about you know these people in the
tragedy was at the beach while he's at
the beach on vacation no comment jumps
in the car and then when he comes back
Pat he avoids you know that path that
they take that Trump takes to get right
to the media talk to them he avoids them
and walks all the way into the grass uh
and the day look tell me this isn't a
spit in the face the day it happens his
administration is asking Congress for 24
more billion dollars to give to Ukraine
that's not a joke okay they're not
getting the help that they want are you
serious I swear to God Pat they were
asking for money it could be 12 or 24
doesn't matter the word b is involved
and uh and here's the thing Pat I'm not
going to conspiracy well first of all
they're not getting the help that they
want they're Biden's going to give them
700 these people lost houses
700 per household to do what what are
you gonna do with that and I'm get away
from mainstream media I've been watching
on tick tock on Instagram
people on the people that live in Maui
pad that live in Hawaii are so furious
at the response they're no help blocking
police from helping them and you know I
thought about that they're not getting
the help that they want why doesn't the
mayor or or whoever just self-identify
change the name to Hawaii to Ukraine
billions of dollars will start coming in
overnight and I don't know like listen
the emergency alarm system the sirens
didn't work Pat that's by the way Maui
has the largest emergency alert siren
system in the world it didn't activate
Rob what else happened with the water
the water system failed uh there's
reports that they had what's called dry
hydrants where the fire hydrants ran out
of water or didn't have any water access
to water and Bob is it just I might be
losing my mind guys isn't Hawaii
surrounded by freaking water and you
couldn't get water on to the fires and
this is disgusting for all these demons
that are out there Pat the day after
everything is done the smoke is start
the fires are done the smoke is settling
real estate agents and people were
calling homeowners asking to buy their
land which just adds to the conspiracy
theories of all these people Oprah
recently bought I think in March another
thousand acres in Maui you know whose
houses didn't burn at all Pat at all
they have Mega
um just this is random I think God
really protects these people Oprah Jeff
Bezos Lady Gaga Bill Gates Morgan
Freeman Will Smith Julia Roberts zero
damage to the house sets and listen
again conspiracies aside I saw the
damage on the ground it didn't look like
fires bro these these cars there was no
glass the glass melted around what is
glass melts at like what 2700 degrees it
looked like a nuke went off Pat I've
been in fires we're from La I've seen
really really really bad fires I've
never seen Vehicles look like how they
did and dogs dead in the street that
looked like they were fake like they
were from the movie uh uh and I was
weird seeing that the response is
horrible Pat the response it's horrible
and this is the United this is the 50th
United States
that should be the health Ukraine time
out for Ukraine go save this place it's
unbelievable and the alarm didn't go off
in the city by the way and I still have
an alarm that goes off it didn't go off
they asked Tulsa gabbard Why didn't it
go off they're like I've heard a lot of
different explanations but I don't
understand why it didn't go off how did
that how does that fail let me um
I guess give my two cents here
um well the number one story on the Wall
Street Journal right now is basically
this story right here Hawaiian Electric
knew of wildfire threat but waited years
to act so four years ago the utility
company said it needed to do more to
prevent power lines from emitting Sparks
and it made basically very little
progress they didn't do anything instead
they were focusing on wait for it a
shift to clean energy so in 2019 which
is I guess there is Wildfire season here
2019 was the worst Wildfire they'd ever
seen until now so
um I trust the Wall Street Journal
um we could you know look for yourself
what's going on here
um I'm not I'm not
You Know It ultimately it's a freaking
tragedy and it's horrible a lot of
people lost their lives I'm not you know
on the conspiracy theorist side of
things at the same time we have every
right to ask questions 100 you know I'm
for most people that go into conspiracy
theories I either think that you fall
into one of three camps either you're
intellectually lazy and you don't
actually do the work and just spout
opinions or you have an agenda and
you're sticking to it and you're not
willing to learn other ideas or facts or
it's a combination of both so if you're
one of the people that actually think
that there was uh larger forces at play
that's cool all good but go read this uh
article from The Wall Street Journal
because there was it just seems like
government incompetence uh laziness
um not doing things uh in a in a
reasonable manner of time uh and then
sprinkle in whatever sort of fraud that
you want to throw in there but this
seems to be this is the number one story
in the Wall Street Journal right now and
they're basically blaming it on a Hawaii
electric Tom do you have any thoughts on
this company oh PGE did the same thing
in California there were those old power
lines up there in the open Forest areas
and the grassland areas in Northern
California uh there's the fire up there
known as the telegraph fire which um
killed a bunch of people in a small town
because the Wildfire pushed by winds
came up there and found out it was
sparking off of PG e it wasn't a
cigarette out of a car it wasn't uh
camps it was an arson it was freaking
arced off electricity and so this is you
know these big power companies that are
you know working with the states and
they have lobbyists to help break the
regulations a lot of the stuff should
have been retrofitted and it wasn't and
now we've got California and Hawaii see
here yeah but this was the largest fire
Wi-Fi in the United States of 2021
suppressed by the bootleg fire in Oregon
look at this and this was and it's not a
shock that this happens in the dead
middle of summer where it's hot as [__]
out we've seen World Records in every
state it's hot it's summer these things
it's just an oh Tragedy yeah but you
know these are these are Americans these
are Americans how do you feel how do you
think they feel when they find out the
date the day after this [__] happens
we're trying to prove more billions to
go to a different country to fight a war
that nobody gives a [__] about I think
that's conflating two stories brother to
be honest with you I'm not complaining
because the response the Ukraine thing
is an ongoing story when Biden's sending
700 per victims
all for 24 billion on that day that's a
whole they're an adventurous that's
completely independent stories no
maybe let me explain the example in a
different way to to kind of uh make
sense to this say you have kids okay
let's say you marry a girl that's got a
kid okay not happening but go ahead but
let's say you marry your kid let me use
the example with you let's say you marry
a girl with a kid yeah then he'll do it
she's got a three-year-old kid okay and
you and her end up having a kid together
okay later on 25 they're they're 18
years old 16 years old for the step kid
you pay 100 a college tuition you buy
him a house you buy them a car you do
all that stuff for your daughter that's
your daughter this is your kid you do
nothing for no College she's got to go
figure it out herself she's a big girl
she's got to do it all herself that
daughter is going to sit there and say
why are you doing more for your step kid
than me I'm your blood why are you not
doing it now we can use this example and
say you did it for your neighbor's kid
because this is not even your stepkid a
step kid maybe maybe a a state that's
you know uh that we're helping out
that's maybe not like our own like we're
helping out some Community around us
because it's a partner that we have in
place now you're doing more for a
neighbor's kid than you're doing for
your own kids so Biden's doing more for
Neighbors kid Ukraine than he's doing
for us having said that I believe it's a
week two weeks three weeks away from
them announcing that they're sending
money over yeah this is not going to
last a long time the problem with that
is
the following the Swift reaction is
where you lose people Swift reaction to
say here's the camera this is how many
people that died the biggest natural
disaster in the history of Hawaii and
guess what happens on Hawaii a lot
weather storm hurricane earthquake on
the outside you know things are coming
in there's some what do you call it the
volcanoes bunch of different things cry
I've walked on the volcanoes with lava
right in front of us took us six hours
to get to the lava there's a lot of
Crisis that can happen in that place
this is the biggest one ever in the
number one honeymoon destination of
Americans they go to Hawaii that is the
place that street in Maui we all have I
bought paintings on that street I've
gone to numbers of restaurants on that
street I've watched the Super Bowl on
that street when the Bears I don't know
was years ago when the Bears had a
decent team and they were playing 2005
2004. I don't know who was years ago I
you we have memories friendships drinks
conversations boom gone people that grew
up they're some of the nicest people in
the world you'll meet when you go to
Hawaii these are people that enjoy life
nature relax and enjoying themselves
there's a reason why all these big
famous people want to buy a place in
Hawaii because you go there you feel
like you're in heaven there's a certain
unique feeling you get in Hawaii can't
describe it unless if you go there
there's something very emotional about
that place my dad and I had a very
unique moment together when I took them
there
February of 2004 when uh he uh I
promised him I said you never have to
work a day in your life at a 99 cent
store I took him there after Hawaii he
started dreaming again and my dad is now
81 years old
he's you know living a complete
different kind of a life that I never
thought he was going to make it to 81.
but we always go back to that moment
everybody has a Hawaii story most people
have a Hawaii story so I don't like the
fact that Biden's not reacting to this
now in regards to what you're saying
which is a very good point when you went
on Twitter that that laser that
everybody fell for no it's a laser was
an intentional laser that's right energy
well that was out of a movie right now
that that act we have access to that
technology if we wanted to do that
technology we do have but that's from a
movie and then another thing that they
were showing was another clip of what
happened an explosion of this that a
bunch of these conspiracies went viral
that's the that's the negative part of
social media that these types of Clips
are going to scare people and react and
all that stuff but you know what else is
good about social media very quickly
people are going to say hey take that
down it's fake that's not real and
you're gonna get fact checked very
quickly in the comments section so then
you either take it down apologize or you
look like a fool if you leave it up
there or you just say I screwed up I do
I am a fool for leaving this up there
guess what I'm going to leave this up
there because I don't want to take you
down you guys are right I was wrong this
is up there you'll comment below
um but three things compassionate I hate
to see something like this happening
number two concerning with all the
conspiracies that got all of us fired up
thinking there's something going on here
extremely Disturbed with the fact that
the president not reacting quickly and
swiftly to do something about it here
four uh Logistics as operators what the
hell is the city doing you've known this
as a the potential resp and by the way
isn't the mayor from Vegas that the
shooting happened what's the story which
is and again adding fuel to the fire of
these conspiracy there is the chief of
police that's in charge of all this is
the same chief of police that was in
Vegas for the man shooting The Mandalay
shooting that's what's his name uh Chief
John Pelletier led the response to 2017
Vegas he's the same chief that was there
that's here now Vegas job he got hired
yeah but how random is that by the way I
mean that's that he's got to have one of
the worst resumes in the history of
America for chief football chief of
police
great power becomes great responsibility
so this guy and it's when you're the
chief of police shit's gonna happen yeah
they're going to follow you to let's see
what happens it's just impact it's a
it's the inconsiderate like and I was
watching like I said a bunch of videos
out of people that were there crying
emotional and one lady didn't hit me
really hard she's like we have people
dead all around here and goes they're
still American like people from America
like here vacationing showing up after
this fire and they're right there
swimming and having a great time and
Meanwhile we're looking for dead dead
it's just sad it's just horrible the
images are horrible I think Pat you I I
fully appreciate the point that you're
making about the kid and the step kid I
actually think that's a great metaphor
it it it it made me like all right cool
Ukraine that's the step kid you know I
would I would also I'm thinking well we
Biden and Trump took care of our kids
during covid stimulus checks the cares
act how 20 trillions of dollars did we
give to ourselves uh I I also agree with
you that we're this just happened this
is not even a week old
FEMA is going to respond the federal
government's going to respond they're
going to help out you got to be swift
though bro like like for example listen
you know uh uh uh
you call me okay like think about this
you call me you say hey Pat what's that
I'm being jumped in Miami by five guys
here bro they all look like Vinnie I'm
being jumped and stay serious I'm in I'm
in my man being jumped by five guys
uh what are you saying dude I need help
I don't know what's going on I'm hiding
in this one spot I can't get a hold of
anybody it's two o'clock in the morning
okay hey Mario wake Vinnie up let's go
boom we're coming down yep now watch
this you call me hey Pat we're Miami
getting jumped okay cool two weeks later
I'm in my ass
I don't need you in Miami in two weeks
come to Miami now there's a big
difference so there's the Swift reaction
is the job of a leader the Swift
reaction is a job of a leader move now
this is Crisis level number ten let's
roll you can't sit there and bulk you're
the commander-in-chief if you reacted
like this and wore thousands of soldiers
would be dead because we're moving so
slowly so it's deeply concerning anyways
we got time to go through a couple other
stories
my next meeting's at 11 30 so we can go
20 more minutes by the way I so look
forward to the day that we can do
podcasts three five days a week I can't
wait for the day that we can just roll
you know doing this kind of stuff
because we're always behind on stories
let's talk about what progress we've
been making folks one thing I want you
to be thinking about why I'm convinced
the future looks bright let me tell you
why I'm convinced the future looks
bright
so uh I'm on uh Joe and I are talking
about ESG okay out of the podcast that
we do they choose to put the clip of GSP
ESG on their uh on their JRE short clips
okay and boom next thing you know that's
posted all over the place yesterday a
clip went viral on like 500 Instagram
accounts hey Larry Fink is the president
not Joe Biden I don't know if you saw
that it's everywhere it's going to
clipped up and it's been taken off okay
then hey this other clip on Twitter then
on Facebook all these stories about well
I didn't know about the fact that all
this institutional money with 88 and
then people started texting me yeah and
and they're like well you know the story
you're saying that there's no way that's
true and then I posted if you go on
Instagram real quick Rob I posted the
truth and I gave people the link on
Instagram to go verify everything I said
I said I want you to go verify me and
the people that were bitching at me were
liberal so the link I get keep going
down the link I gave to them was a link
from CNN keep going down keep going that
it's just words you'll see CNN all the
way at the top keep going that you'll
find it so I posted this that right
there if you can click on that so this
is from CNN talking about BlackRock and
15 trillion dollar fund industry should
be broken up anti-monopoly group says
combined BlackRock State Street and
Vanguard are the owners 88 of SMP
largest owners of 88 this is CNN 88 of s
p 500 companies according to paper The
Big Three are responsible for between 73
to 80 percent of global ETF market and
45 out of 50 largest funds according it
continues you can read the entire
article then at the bottom BlackRock
manages more than 87 billion dollars
worth of shares and fossil fuel
companies and as opposed and abstain
about 80 percent
which is talking about you know nuclear
all this other stuff that it's going
through you can go read this article
from CNN for yourself moral of the story
when we started talking about it
everybody started talking about it and
everybody started researching this is
why I believe the future looks bright
because one can watch this however many
people can watch today's podcast then
they're going to say let me go research
this let me go look at this let me go
look at this who's this Larry finkai
who's by the way I'd love to talk to
Larry Fink if he's open to the I'd love
to have a fair interview with you and
you know we can cover different discs
I'd love fly out have a conversation I'd
love to do that with you so to what
about this and what about that and what
about this my God the more I'm
researching this why are they doing this
why are they doing that within two weeks
what happens McDonald's removes all ESG
words out of their website weird
immediately they remove all ESG words
off their website and then outside of
McDonald's other companies start doing
it one by one by one by one by one they
drop the acronym so phase number one is
what the acronym is now a curse word so
first they're just removing references
of ES G and you can read this article by
attendant.com written by Connor Walcott
you can go find this article a rap
so they first remove the ESG names but
not the principles so the principles are
still there right the principles are
still there then SMP drops ESG scale
from its debt ratings a sigh of relief
for capitalism this is when it becomes
big when SMP is now reacting to it so
let's read this article together s p
drops ESG from its debt debt ratings
aside really for capitalism uh SMP and
Global major corporate debt Raider
eliminated corporate environmental
social and governance scores from its
debt ratings responding to criticism and
concerns over political bias linked to
ESG practices that means guys folks
we're making progress the people are
being heard you matter when people say
my vote doesn't matter this is
validating that your voice matters the
great equalizer today is called social
media they should have never invented
this because yesterday I'm telling
Russell Brand I said Russell you know
why I believe the future looks right he
says why I said let me get this straight
I said you know who you are on my eyes
he says who oh not the shirt you know
inside of you inside right I'm saying he
starts cracking up I said you were an
a-lister you were an a-lister actor
dating some of the hottest girls in
Hollywood with your accent you entertain
the world Forgetting Sarah Marshall what
the hell are you doing talking about you
don't even like capitalists we were not
on the same page with capitalism why are
you talking you've ruined your Hollywood
career as an a-lister to be picked up
and you think Russell Brand's ever going
to be in Snow White Never you think it's
gonna be in these movies that's coming
up I said let me get this straight
you're a Hollywood guy an a-lister I'm
an insurance Financial guy what the hell
are we doing starting media companies
and podcasts that's a sign that future
looks Bright Beautiful two different
Industries so let me continue reading
this to you
and I'll come to you guys so SMP ESG
ratings introduced in 2021 on a one to
five scale presumed companies to align
with specific non-financial factors
again align with specific none
non-financial factors often leading to a
loss of consumer connection and
financial burdens for compliance esg's
influence emphasizing factors beyond
Financial considerations LED
corporations to prioritize aspects like
diversity equity and environmental
friendliness this shift is criticized
for diverting Focus from consumers in
traditional capitalism ultimately
influencing business to a pcsg rating
firms and guess what SMP is now saying
guys we're stepping away from it this is
a black eye
4 the DI Community for Soros Community
Four State Street Vanguard BlackRock all
of those guys and Soros apparently Ward
came out yesterday Rob about the fact
that they're leaving what EU and they're
closing a bunch of their offices in EU
because the sun is not taking over Alex
so the people have spoken and more
people are saying you guys are full of
[__] we don't like this ESG stuff leave
it alone stay focused on the business
principles instead of forcing an
Anheuser-Busch to send beer to somebody
called Dylan Mulvaney who's not going to
drink the Bud Light beer you just kind
of want to be woke and you lost billions
of dollars so thoughts I love it and
that bleeds into another story that I
looked over right there Target reported
its first sales drop in six years after
the pride month disaster it's like and
and Pat I'm not gonna lie I fell victim
to what you were saying where I'm like
the vote doesn't count nobody can hear
us I felt like claustrophobic but these
are beautiful moments and you are right
about the future that without being loud
and whatever just just us alone just by
our actions like things do change and
like Target you think Target's not going
to change their woke ideology after this
this this month they're they're done
they're gonna shift gears well there's
multi phases to this and we need to keep
our foot on the pedal America this is
just taking the phrase ESG off the
websites and backing off from it there
are still things that are underneath
below the surface and make sure your
voice stays heard as McDonald says well
we'll probably still leave some of the
principles intact and you know talk
about a broader shift in our corporate
messaging and cultural and political
debates no ESG I was reading an article
that Americans were confusing ESG with
equal opportunity it's not equal
opportunity is necessary so every person
no matter where you come from as an
opportunity for a job that's that is
fabric of America and that needs to be
intact but when you turn it into you
know ESG and you start putting all these
non-financial measures and I'm going to
arbitrary really measure on a one to
five scale I am so glad that s p starts
it in 21 it's not even the end of 23 now
and they killed this thing in its crib
I'm glad because this is not what people
want in terms of the expression of
wokism and more importantly all
Americans want equal opportunity for
people but this wokeism and everything
that goes with it is not what they
wanted and keep your foot on the gas
that this doesn't hide in the tall grass
and keep being used even though they
take ESG off the website you know you
know what's the biggest thing the people
of power fear
the people we talk about this with Rogan
and foreign populace not just informed
populace that's one you're right let's
add that to the list you know what they
fear men and women who have Faith and
Hope in a brighter future they fear that
they want you to be defeated
they have to battle with boxing someone
is what to look at the eye and say that
guy's already defeated it's time over
yep one of the scariest things when you
fight Buster Douglas and you look at him
in the eyes and you say I don't know why
this guy's looking at me this way he
looks like he's got faith that night he
fought for his mom that had just died
less than 30 days prior to the fight wow
and he won the fight the scariest look
in a man's eye is when he or she has a
look of hope faith and fearlessness in a
higher power that the future is going to
be fine folks stay optimistic
stay faithful stay hopeful the future
looks bright it is the most scariest
opponent for the government or the
establishment or the people of power to
have when we collectively believe our
voice is being heard and our voice
matters don't go to your kids or your
peers or your co-workers or say this
nonsense about your vote and your voice
doesn't matter I've said that before
when I was coming up and I was a 22-23
year old kid you know what that language
is that's a language of a defeated
person we are not defeated people we're
leaders and we're finding each other the
other day I'm in front of our team and
headquarters guy just drives up to us
Mario thinks this guy's going to come
out he's going to do something he runs
up to the gate this happened yesterday
I'm like okay Mario's ready we're ready
we don't know what's going to happen it
just kind of was sudden that this
happened and we're both looking at him
to see how he's walking and all of a
sudden he comes closer closer closer
closer so this guy's a fan and he just
said let's man I just wanted to say you
know it's it's it's it's great to see
what you guys are doing you know I work
down the street I see the logo here all
the time I've been watching him for this
many years I just love that you're
pushing the album
and I said you want me to tell you why
the future looks bright he says why I
said because like-minded people are
finding each other and that is scary
like in the movie I Am Legend they all
went and found each other in this place
called Vermont and when they opened the
doors there's light and you hear the
sound of church they don't want you to
believe in God faith hope they don't
want you to do that
and it's happening and that's freaking
awesome I love it that's freaking
awesome anyways if you had final
thoughts I want to go to the last two
stories before we wrap it yeah I mean
ultimately what this comes down to is
the story of capitalism here in America
right I mean that's essentially
everything that we love and appreciate
the free markets the free enterprise you
talked about compassionate capitalism
earlier today we talked about crony
capitalism last night you know then
there's this woke capitalism that sort
of seeped into
um into major companies and to
corporations these days but as we've
learned
um go woke go broke certain companies
can withstand go and woke like we saw
with Nike and Colin Kaepernick certain
companies certainly cannot right so Bud
Light No Bueno with Dylan Mulvaney okay
Target with your man tuck weird Satan
whatever it's Satan stuff whatever okay
um Disney we're seeing you know they're
going to woke um so I did I think you
interviewed Noam Chomsky I think he he
wrote the book what um profits over
people and that was a knock on certain
corporations and capitalism but
um there's the reverse side to it is
that when you put wokeness over profits
um there will be hell to pay and people
ain't having it anymore so
um bad policies are getting exposed
exactly that's the best thing bad
policies takes time to get exposed
Common Sense reveals itself and then
people say ah I can't believe I once
believed in that thing you ever dated
somebody and then a year later you're
like what the hell was I doing dating
this all the time not actually for you
it's different you're dating me like I
don't really care I'm just having a good
time so yeah but okay let's go through
this two stories one Rob I'm gonna
combine two stories here together so
play the clip Rob if you can find it
from Supermarket not Supermarket Topanga
Mall where three hundred thousand
dollars of supplies was stolen from this
place which our office was at Warner
Center Marriott across the street from
Topanga Mall this is the mall I would go
to my shopper who would pick out my
clothes worked at Topanga Mall she would
pick my clothes I would go there and I
would buy the stuff this is them I'll
play this clip check this out watch this
three hundred thousand dollars
California policies let's go Kelly
look at the guy over there doesn't know
what to do should I take a shirt or
should I run yeah
wow
look at that the expensive bag that's
wired that's got the anti-theft wiring
to the
shelves she's just gonna take the
shelves with him
okay pause it now that's California
right let me tell you how stupid these
policies are stay with me here folks San
Francisco's
representative Kylie says crime is so
out of control that you ready that
employees
are instructed not to drive to work
can you please pull this article Abraham
they're instructed not to drive to work
what the hell do you mean they're
instructed not to drive to work well
because it's not safe
for their employees who the hell says
stuff like this are we living in a third
world country okay let me let me
continue reading this what page does
this sound for me to read page 15. okay
here we go
so a representative Kevin Kiley okay
California highlight San Francisco
rampant crime due to failed policies
radical politics and political public
corruption revealing that Federal
Building employees were told to stay
home due to the conditions around the
building according to a Department of
Health and Human Services memo memo
major businesses including Whole Foods
Nordstroms T-Mobile Sachs and
anthropology have left San Francisco due
to Rising crimes causing what Kelly
describes as a total collapse in the
city homicides robberies vehicle thefts
have surge leading to a population drop
of 70 000 people from 2019 to 2022 The
Exodus from San Francisco has resulted
in crime affecting affluent areas with
rampant larceny's drug crimes comparable
to the 80s and a lack of police
visibility bad policies have
consequences and our people are paying
the price for Tom Rob roll back to that
article you were just looking at just go
back and roll up up up up up
I'm going to read one paragraph quick in
the memo Health and Human Services
advise workers to maximize the use of
telework for the foreseeable future
because of the conditions around
18-story building that houses various
federal agencies including Health Human
Services and Department of Labor and
transportation so the people that caused
it are now trapped outside their castles
the people that caused it are now like
hey y'all stay away from the castle here
it ain't safe this blows me away this is
not government coming in there and
saying hey you get a really bad
situation here we got to protect our
people get away from the embassy that's
in um this city because there's um
things going on here so stay away from
the embassy this is not the government
saying that this is the freaking
government saying uh we want our people
to stay away from our buildings because
after our policies created this this
mess but they don't want to own it take
the accountability for fixing it
shocking to me absolutely shocking yeah
I read an article you have to look it up
they told Nancy Pelosi like don't come
to this Federal Building because it's
just but it's basically getting overrun
I saw the outside area Tom it's just all
junkies crackheads everybody's outside
but then think about it Tom she can't go
home because when she is home or when
she's not there there's a butt naked guy
that's running in there and trying to
you know I'll be with her husband
because there's a normal Tuesday and the
Pelosi house yeah because there's a
musician in her driveway saying it's
hammer time I'll tell you what this is
why I love Florida okay let me tell you
something Buddy we've been talking about
Snow White and all the Disney stuff and
you know I'm gonna use the little three
bears analogy you go too far left you
end up in [__] San Francisco crime
ridden Ridiculousness you go too far
right you're out and
West Virginia super far right you know
all that stuff in Florida Welcome to
purple Florida we sometimes we're a
little more red these days sometimes
we'll get a little more blue all good
but it's normal and it's free and
there's not nonsense going on from Super
woke left or super alt right and that's
why I love Florida but can you imagine
that not just really fast but this this
is from that stupid defund the police
and then why would you as a as a
governor say you know what under a
thousand dollars 908.98 We're Not Gonna
even stop you and if you work in the
business you can't stop the person or
you're gonna be the one against this
this is not going to work long term good
for them because it's not going to work
long term because bad policies have
consequences that's it you have to have
faith in that Faith Hope informed all of
those if we have faith hope informed
Fearless we are finding each other
period Last Story here to wrap up
Armenia what's going on with them
mainstream media is not talking about
this a lot Armenians face genocide in
azerbai Azerbaijan former international
criminal court prosecutor warns this is
AP News a couple days ago
the former ICC Chief prosecutor Luis
Moreno Ocampo warns of an impending
genocide against ethnic Armenians in
Azerbaijan naguna karabakh region
urging the U.N security Council to
intervene a Campos report highlights
azerbaijan's blockade of the sole Road
connecting Armenia to nagornbach
severely impeding supplies for 120 000
residents these are 120 000 people and
risking a humanitarian catastrophe the
reports notes that there's reasonable
basis to believe that a genocide is
being committed right now this situation
emerged after armenia-backed forces
controlled until a 2020 war with a compo
urging the security Council including
Russia and the U.S to act and prevent a
worsening crisis and this continues with
other stories that are asking for
support and you know Nicole pashinians
talking about uh issues a stark warning
asserting that if it's Azerbaijan
obstructs humanitarian Aid via the
legion Corridor it will prove that its
real goal is to starve the people of
nagorno kharabakh and to subject them to
genocide pashunan reveals the
humanitarian relief has reached corenzor
the gateway to Latin Corridor but
Azerbaijan is hindering its passage
amplifying an eight-month long
humanitarian crisis he condemns
obstruction an incomprehensible and
unacceptable passion and challenges
Azerbaijan stated pretext for blocking
the corridors saying what does
Azerbaijan not allow this cargo to enter
nagorno is it not because the real goal
of Azerbaijan is to start the people in
subject them to genocide so when you
hear a story like this there's a couple
different things
Ukraine and Russia okay that's a example
of what Russia and Ukraine to have the
conflict with each other Armenia you
have Azerbaijan okay and then you have
this area that used to be theirs that is
now ours and now they're kind of sharing
it together it's kind of like East
Ukraine and you know West Ukraine it's
like this Ukraine they all speak Russian
this Ukraine is different so I
understand on the East Ukraine side it's
more like this ukrainians there's an
element of that going on here but what
you don't hear about
with this proxy award that's going on
between Ukraine and Russia you don't
hear about Russians preventing Ukrainian
people from eating food or vice versa
that's not happening there they just
have a war that's going on between the
two of them okay what is happening here
with Armenia and Azerbaijan it's a
long-standing genocide that happened
many many years over a century ago April
24 1915 over a century ago a million and
a half to 2.2 million Armenians
Assyrians and Greeks you and I are
Assyrian I'm Armenian and Greeks are
part of this that now some I don't know
what the number is 60 plus countries
have said no this is an event that took
place there's a great movie that was
done by Kirk Krikorian uh where
Christian Bale is in the movie
highlighting what the motive was behind
the insurance policies and if you've
never seen it you've got to go watch
this movie I think it's called The
Promise Rob if you can pull up the movie
but it's tragic what's going on there I
know in La Adam Schiff believe it or not
is going out there writing a letter I
believe to Biden saying we got to do
something about this and Adam Schiff is
a guy from the left that sit down
they're saying we've got to do something
about this it's catastrophic it's
heartbreaking that this is happening but
at the same time I hope mainstream media
starts talking about this so it gets the
attention of people because there's
there's different kinds of support
there's the support you give to Ukraine
because you want Putin to fall because
you don't like Putin right that's kind
of like you're you're you're getting
involved in elections kind of like this
gentleman from China that said about
what they're doing in U.S to hurt kind
of the candidates it's a speech that we
haven't played yet and then there's
difference between that versus
supporting what's going on in Hawaii or
actually helping people that are in
major need because a genocide is taking
place but you don't want to get involved
because Azerbaijan Azerbaijan is linked
to Turkey and turkey's erdogan and they
now have one of the best militaries in
turkey and he just recently won an
election which was very weird because a
lot of Turkish people to buy yeah us
yeah built by us so so deeply concerning
it's something that
um you know
you know when I sat down with Tate and
then Tate and Tucker had a conversation
with Azerbaijan in the comments that was
made about Azerbaijan we don't know all
the stories about everybody I'm about to
have a debate here with two folks that
are pro-muslim and two folks that were
not and they've all agreed to come and
do this I can't wait for this podcast
going to be in the next month or two
it's going to be great I've been having
a lot of conversations with Muslims
because I think this is a conversation
that I want to have
um
the folks especially the leaders at the
top of Azerbaijan and turkey what
they're doing with Armenians is a
travesty and I think when something like
this happens where people are standing
in line for hours to get bred some areas
don't have water food medicine kids are
sick they don't have access to the basic
stuff that you need on a daily basis
it's catastrophic so our prayers goes
out to the folks there and we hope more
people talk about this to bring
attention to what's really going on over
there uh having said that uh today's
what today's Tuesday or Thursday
Thursday is Thursday Thursday uh Rob do
we have podcasts uh when's the next
podcast we have a podcast Tuesday and
Tuesday Thursday afternoon and Friday of
next week Tuesday Thursday afternoon and
Friday yeah so we're doing three next
week so your dreams coming true you
talked about it you put it out there
gang if you're watching this we're about
to announce our next town hall okay
we're about to announce our next town
hall in our next live podcast the one
I'm trying to put together is going to
be freaking epic and those tickets are
going to sell out and all you guys that
message me afterwards pissed off saying
I wish I would have bought a ticket if
you don't want to be part of that camp
text award podcast to
310-340-1132 again text award podcast to
310-340-1132 because you're always the
first to get the link to the next guest
at our live event so if you're not on
that text distribution list you are not
going to get it having said that have a
great weekend everybody we'll do this
again next week take care bye bye
podcast look once a year we host a
conference called The Vault conference
it's our Super Bowl where 3 000
entrepreneurs CEOs executive sales
people from around the world come
together to spend three and a half days
together from August 30th to September
2nd at the Diplomat Resort in Miami to
learn how to scale their business how to
identify their next 5 10 15 moves who to
recruit next who to go raise their money
from how to raise Capital how to
properly skill culture retention higher
fire all of those things and much more
and we do that over a span of three and
a half days and the reason why it's a
very important season to attend a
conference like this the following
reason today there's three different
types of people they're scared they're
those that are content and the obsessed
they're scared they don't want to do
anything because they're worried about
what's going to happen in the economy
they're going to take a big hit the
content they're walking around saying
life is pretty okay I don't need to do
anything else and then there's the
obsessed because they see a massive
opportunity today so imagine spending
three and a half days with three
thousand obsessed people that want to
grow on a seasonal like this imagine how
much you can run from just those
relationships and networks so on top of
the people that are going to be
attending at this event this probably
the best lineup we'll ever have out of
all conference Tom Brady seven time
Champion I'll be interviewing him he'll
be at the Vault conference Mike Tyson
will gudara the gentleman who ran the
restaurant 11 Madison New York that went
from a regular restaurant to a one
Michelin star two Michelin star three
Michelin stars and eventually the number
one restaurant in the world he's gonna
talk about how they treat their
customers so look if you've not
registered yeah this is my
recommendation to you I never went to
conferences when I was coming up by
myself I always went with a spouse with
a business partner or running mate
because I only have a lens on what I see
every night afterwards we would sit
there and say what was your biggest
takeaway so get yourself your spouse
your partner your running mate
registered to come spend three and a
half days with us at the Diplomat Resort
in Miami from August 30th to September
2nd I will see you there
foreign
[Music]